hello everyone welcome to the june 2022
ask me anything edition of the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll and
as many of you know uh if you're
listening in contemporary times mid-2022
and you're a podcast listener you know
that i am in the midst of moving from
the west coast to the east coast of the
united states from los angeles to
baltimore from caltech to johns hopkins
it's a lot of work moving finding a
house packing things all sorts of things
as you grow older you accumulate more
stuff and we got to move our stuff into
a new place um so anyway the point of me
mentioning that is i have no amusing
anecdotes to begin this ama with i just
gotta like try to squeeze out time to
answer the actual questions that were
put in front of me so let's do that
let's go
[Music]
dan o'neil says do you think that the
concept of emergence could be useful in
advocating for abortion rights in this
case the idea that a human being is an
emerging phenomenon that develops
gradually through the course of
gestation to someone who believes that a
human person with full legal rights
comes into being at the moment a sperm
fertilizes an egg or at some other very
early stage of pregnancy the mother's
right to privacy or control of her own
body will never justify what they
consider to be first-degree murder it
seems to me that the profound question
of what is and is not a human person
should be addressed more directly by the
pro-choice movement
so when i first read the very first
sentence of the of the question here do
you think that the concept of emergence
should be useful could be useful in
advocating for abortion rights i was
thinking this is not worth answering but
in fact this is a great question uh the
way that it developed so thanks for
asking this dan and it's something that
i've addressed in not quite these terms
but elsewhere uh in blog posts and
things like that i don't think that
emergence is the central issue here but
the nature of what is a living being
is absolutely central and emergence has
something to do with that but
really the distinction here as far as i
can tell is not so much between you know
how exactly does emergence happen or
something like that but
physicalism versus some kind of dualism
right do you think that human beings are
collections of particles obeying the
laws of nature or do you think there's
some fundamentally distinct essence
that inhabits them and gives them a soul
or a mind or something like that that
would be the dualist perspective
and of course many religious traditions
believe exactly that many scientific
traditions are much more physicalist
about things
it's a very hard
discussion to have with people right but
i guess what i want to say is
i do agree that we should have the
discussion so yes is the short answer to
the what i take to be the spirit of your
question the way that i put it in my
blog posts is that ontology matters to
discussions of public policy and this is
exactly a case so
to step back a bit from the specifics of
the abortion debate uh we have a a way
of generating laws and policies in our
democratic republic that involves
morality involves values i mean of
course it does how could it not
we try to have policies that lead to
good outcomes well what does that mean
good right you have to have some
normative component of your thought
there you have to have some way of
judging what is good and what is bad
that's values that's philosophy that's
morality
and yet we disagree
about some very fundamental issues
within the realm of morality this is has
been and always will be the fundamental
challenge of democracy to live in a
democracy you have to on the one hand
have some common values right you have
the people who live in the democracy
have to have some things in common so
they can get along but on the other hand
be willing to live with
disagreement about some other
fundamental values
and make compromises right that's what
democracy is all about and when it comes
to you know life and death sometimes
people are not willing to make these
compromises so it becomes hard it
becomes a challenge to the very notion
of democracy
having said all that so anyway short
answer is yes um it would i think that
we
in practice
make a bunch of laws
based on some very vague and hand wavy
and disreputable ideas about morality
and the morality is there but it's not
very sophisticated it's not very careful
and many of the ideas that we have would
not stand up to closer philosophical
scrutiny i would like those discussions
to be at a much higher level much more
sophisticated and much more informed by
how we think about these things at a
philosophical moral ethical etc level
not to mention on an ontological level
um
but there's also the fact that i think
that it's not really true that a lot of
opponents of abortion consistently hold
this point of view some do
many do not uh this has been pointed out
many many times
if you really thought this was true
you would literally convict people of
murder for doing abortions um
and furthermore there's plenty of times
when people miscarry or otherwise um
a fertilized egg does not come to term
as a healthy baby and what do you do in
those circumstances furthermore if you
cared all that much you might want to
care about the lives of these children
after they were born as well as before
they were born and so on and so on um
there are various things that you know
it's too long a discussion to go into
right now there are various
reasons why people are on the
anti-abortion side of things other than
some principled philosophical idea about
dualism and the insolent of the person
at the moment of conception that's just
something to keep in mind when you have
these discussions if the point is we
should be more honest in our discussions
that's got to be a component of it
kyle stevens says con consciousness only
perceive a single direction of time if i
were to create a simulated world that
was able to run forwards and backwards
in time could a hypothetical conscious
simulated observer in this world
perceive the direction switching
so the short answer is yes consciousness
can only perceive a single direction of
time uh there's probably footnotes there
and it becomes complicated because the
world only has a single direction of
time so whenever we talk about these
questions we're extrapolating our
knowledge beyond the actual world which
is always a dangerous thing to do
but the deeper answer is you have to sit
down and really think about what you
mean by the direction of time so you say
you know could a hypothetical conscious
simulated observer perceive the
direction switching
what does it mean for the direction of
time to switch do you mean that the
entropy of the entire system is going
down because that doesn't just happen
right i mean there's no way that in the
laws of physics if entropy has been
going up for a long time it can start
going down in the whole universe and
then start going back up again and then
start going down that's just not things
that happen so it's sort of a hypothesis
contrary to fact situation
uh roughly speaking our consciousness as
a process through time depends on the
increase of entropy so roughly speaking
if entropy were going down according to
someone's directionality uh in their
time coordinate then consciousness would
perceive the direction of lower entropy
as the past and the direction of higher
entropy as the future
and they would always live in that
direction of time so the the short
version of that statement is
consciousness always perceives entropy
to be increasing along what it calls the
direction of time but even that is not
you know you shouldn't take those
statements too seriously because there
are different ways for entropy to
increase and decrease
if you are not a closed system but an
open system is part of a bigger system
your entropy can go down without any
reversal in the arrow of time if you're
a closed system where entropy is going
down then then you would perceive the
arrow of time the other way all of which
to say it's very complicated and very
far outside um our everyday human
experience so you just have to think
really carefully about what you mean by
these questions
okay i'm going to group two questions
together also about the era of time but
they're going to bring in many worlds so
brad malt says could many worlds explain
the arrow of time that is once the world
has split i assume it cannot come back
together
otherwise multiple copies of oneself
would need to be merged
so doesn't the proliferation of worlds
in a unidirectional manner imply the
time can only evolve in one irreversible
direction and then robert ruxin rescue
says would taking the many world's
interpretations seriously fix the low
entropy at the big bang problem after
all we're just in one of the possible
branches of the decay of the
inflationary period which is a
radioactive quantum process
there are probably countless of branches
in which the entropy is high and no
living beings exist we simply find
ourselves in one compatible with us
existing so basically enanthropic
reasoning
so um in both cases the answer is no
many worlds could not explain the arrow
of time or the low entropy at the big
bang not by itself i mean i think that
many worlds is right so whatever the
right explanation is will be compatible
with many worlds but you can't just say
many worlds there for an arrow of time
in any simple straightforward way
otherwise people would have said it so
to the first idea from brad um yes it is
true that the world's branch toward the
future not the past but that's not an
explanation for the arrow of time that's
because there's an arrow of time it's
because there is a special initial
condition that there was a small number
of branches to start and they branch
toward the future it's exactly the same
statement as saying there was a small
entropy and it grows toward the future
so you need to explain why there was
only one branch at early times that's
the same demand of explanation that you
usually have for the arrow of time and
likewise with robert's question could
you explain the low energy the big bang
here it's a little bit different because
you're saying well there's many
different branches some of them entry
will go up some will go down we'll
always find ourselves in the way in a
branch where entropy is going up in the
right way
that's true but it doesn't work
quantitatively it doesn't work at the
level of actually explaining the world
we observe because the entropy of our
big bang local universe was way way way
way lower than it needs to be for any
anthropic purpose
the entropy of the early universe was
enormously smaller than it needs to be
and one reflection of that is
as it grows right as the universe
expands and entropy increases
you make like a trillion galaxies
so you're taking the amount of matter
that was in a low entropy state it's
enough to make a trillion galaxies very
very roughly speaking why was there that
much stuff in this low entropy state you
know you could have had a universe that
was much much closer to thermal
equilibrium but maybe there was a
fluctuation that made one galaxy rather
than just a trillion right and then
you'd be plenty able to make human
beings or any other kind of life-form
you want and such fluctuations into just
one galaxy or even just one solar system
or a few solar systems those are much
much much much more common than
fluctuations into our whole universe i
did write a paper if you want to look it
up with matt johnson and anthony aguirre
anthony of course was a former mindscape
guest where we go into the details of
what it would look like to fluctuate
from thermal equilibrium into a low
entropy big bang it's very very unlikely
you just basically wind the whole clock
of the universe backwards that's
unlikely at every single step along the
way
so jimmy summer says i've heard argued
that regardless of the crisis being
solved slowing progress should never be
an option because there will always be
more problems to solve down the line
that will require that continued
progress to solve for example climate
change needs a solution but in this
framing slowing down progress for the
sake of reducing fossil fuel use would
be counterproductive in the long run
i've heard arguments like this uh in
fact in a slightly different context
tyler cowan who was an early guest made
an argument like this but no i don't i
don't buy it at all i mean and part of
it is just
the statement being made is so
hopelessly vague that it's impossible to
argue for it being right or wrong right
slowing progress should never be an
option i mean that's a rather grandiose
claim um it depends right the details
matter for something like this so i mean
i don't think it's true but imagine that
climate change were so bad that it was
truly an existential threat to the very
existence of human life right maybe in
the next 50 years climate change
literally wipes off every human being
from the face of the earth again i don't
think that's a
realistic worry but maybe it was and if
it were you can't say well let's just
accelerate the rate of climate change
because sunday we'll find an answer to
it because you'll be dead before you can
find an answer to it okay and that's a
problem i don't think that any
simple-minded model like this is going
to get you the right answer these are
complicated questions you're gonna have
to think through the details a little
bit more carefully
jeffrey seagal says i very much enjoyed
your conversation with nick lane at one
point you mentioned biologists thinking
of natural selection as a mechanism that
improves things but couldn't could
natural selection be a form of the
second law of thermodynamics if
increased complexity of life leads to
increased entropy then perhaps natural
selection is nature's heuristic for
increasing entropy in an ecosystem
well short answer is no i don't think
that's quite right but longer answer is
they are related to each other and but
the relationship is that i've said this
before the arrow of time which is a
result of increasing entropy
is prior to everything else prior to
every
process that has a directionality in
time and that includes biological
evolution so
biological evolution definitely has a
directionality right we started with
some single-celled organisms now we have
a rich ecosystem that's an arrow of time
the only reason why there is an arrow of
time is because entropy is increasing
therefore you know instantly that
without entropy increasing you wouldn't
get biological evolution and natural
selection in the same way the converse
is not true the converse doesn't even
make sense because you can't say well
could you have natural selection without
entropy increasing because well you
can't say what if you had natural
selection without entropy increasing
because you can't okay
so but the point is that
entropy increasing is the first thing
the important thing the prior thing it
may or may not lead to increased
complexity and natural selection natural
selection or other manifestations of
complexity are one of the sets of things
that can happen when entropy is
increasing but it's not the only way for
entropy to increase so the way to think
about it is that the increasing entropy
allows for the possibility of natural
selection but it doesn't cause it and
it's not you know necessary in any way
for entropy increase
i'm going to group two questions
together
about self-identity in many worlds so
tony ranji says if there are many worlds
is there reason to restrict the idea of
me to just the world i experience are we
like a tree with many branches but only
experiencing one branch and peter
blankenheim says you recently explained
that we can map a universe splitting
decoherence event as spreading at the
speed of light or as splitting the whole
universe instantly and get the same
predictions i think you said this is
because the many worlds are strong
emergence phenomena and don't exist in
fundamental physics i also think you
said that the many me's in the many
worlds are each a real person with a
real conscience
for instance to the extent that people
have real consciences
i'm not quite sure peter if you mean
consciousness rather than conscious
conscience but maybe you do anyway these
two truths suggest that my personhood
knowledge of which many philosophers say
is the primary and only unquestionable
knowledge i have
is knowledge of something that does not
exist in fundamental physics did i get
that right
so that last part yes you got completely
right the point here is that personhood
is not anywhere to be found in
fundamental physics as as a statement i
would agree with that i have to disagree
with a couple things
the the phrase strong emergence which
we'll talk about again later is a
specific meaningful phrase in the
philosophical context and many worlds
are not strong emergent phenomena
they're what are called weakly emergent
phenomena that is to say they're just
ways of describing what is going on at
the microscopic level the other thing to
point out is that this has nothing to do
with many worlds even if there was only
one world it would still be true that
personhood is a higher level emergent
phenomena when you look at the laws of
physics at the fundamental phenome
fundamental level the core theory or the
standard model or whatever there's no
persons in there right they're clearly
higher level um
emergent ways of talking about what goes
on in this complex world to tony's
question um
is there reason to restrict the idea of
me to just the world i experience yes
there is it's not like a tree at all i
mean the set of all
cop future copies of your present you is
like a tree but it's not exactly like a
tree because the branches are out of
contact with each other and that is why
you restrict the idea of you to each
world
once the other people are on other
branches nothing that happens to them
affects you and nothing that happens to
you affects them there's literally zero
sense in which those those different
copies of you constitute a coherent
physical system they are separate
non-interacting things they're each a
person it's not like there are many
copies of you and one of them is the
real you they're each many people okay
and and you are one and there are others
who are others that's the right way to
think about it so to go back to peter's
question uh well what about these
philosophers who say that personhood is
the primary and only unquestionable
knowledge i have uh they're wrong
i mean i don't think there's any
unquestionable knowledge that you have
but i certainly don't think that it's
primary it's certainly not primary when
you consider the relationship of
personhood to fundamental physics
kunal menda says if i want to simulate a
dynamical system i would write its state
derivative as a function of time and its
state and then integrate i'm implicitly
assuming however the time is an
objective quantity when doing this if i
understand relativity correctly then you
cannot say the universe is in some state
at some given time because it depends on
the reference frame i want them i want
to then know how laplace's demon would
dynamically evolve the universe do they
have to assume a reference frame when
doing so is there some invariance in the
frame they could choose that makes it
not matter uh yeah it's exactly that
ladder bit
and you don't need to be laplace's demon
to do that you can be any undergraduate
doing a problem in a problem set in
special relativity right uh you can
still in special relativity solve
equations or in general relativity for
that matter for the evolution of the
universe starting with an initial state
and integrating it forward in time but
there is an invariance there's a
symmetry a relativity if you will that
says that you can choose many different
possible
slices of space time on which to frame
your initial conditions okay many
different reference frames in which you
could give the data that laplace's demon
would need to integrate forward in time
and that's perfectly fine there's
nothing in the original construction
that required the way that you stated
your initial data to be unique right as
long as you can state it once and for
all in a way that is sufficient and
necessary to integrate forward and
backward in time that's all you need and
relativity is saying there are many many
ways of doing that that's fine that
shouldn't bother you at all
jonathan m goodson says i have questions
about the familiar statement that the
wave function contains all the
information that can be known about a
particle
what makes people think it's true how
confident are you in its accuracy and
how could one reconcile this statement
with john bell's well-known dictum that
either the wave function is given by the
schrodinger equation is not everything
or it is not right well you know we
don't know that it's true there are
people who think that maybe it's not
true that the wave function contains all
the information that can be known what
we know is the following if you know the
wave function you're able to make all
the predictions for what the particle is
going to do okay there's no no one has
ever come up with a way of making better
predictions than the wave function plus
the born rule are able to give you um
you're allowed therefore to only use the
wave function and to say that that
contains all the information because
there's nothing extra that you get from
imagining more information you're also
allowed to imagine there is more
information but that more information is
just forever hidden from you that's what
people do who like boaming mechanics
pilot wave theories hidden variable
theories right
personally i don't see what is being
gained by doing that but you're allowed
to do it so how confident am i pretty
darn confident but certainly not a
hundred percent finally uh bell's
statement about the wave function either
not obeying the schrodinger equation or
not being everything uh well he was
discounting many worlds you know in
bell's theorem there is an axiom a
postulate a premise of the argument that
says that measurement outcomes have
unique values which is just not true in
many worlds in many worlds measurement
outcomes have all possible values just
on different worlds so it just doesn't
apply
so i mean basically bella's saying
assume many worlds is wrong then many
worlds is wrong that's completely true
but uh doesn't mean many worlds is wrong
as an argument all by itself
dan inch says recent global events are
reminding us that nuclear weapons still
exist as i understand it these weapons
were developed fairly shortly after the
underlying physics word was discovered
how much of a risk do you think there is
that modern physics has paved the way
for something as bad or worse is there a
dark matter bomb on the horizon or an
evaredian bomb
i think that uh there's very very tiny
risk to be honest and the reason why is
because as i've talked about in other
contexts
fundamental physics has passed a
threshold it has passed a threshold
where the stuff of the world around us
is accounted for by fundamental physics
the thing about nuclear weapons and
radioactivity and fission infusion was
they were always there they were always
happening right atoms are decaying in
your body even before we knew about it
and the sun is fusing uh nuclei together
and making power from them that was
happening before we figured it out okay
so what we did was we figured out
something that was there all around us
and we put it to use in making bombs as
well as making other kinds of technology
and now since the laws of physics
underlying our everyday world are
completely understood that's not
happening anymore we get the stuff that
is around us there will it almost
certainly be more stuff be new physics
that we invent so dark matter is an
example where we think that there's
something there but we don't know
exactly what it is
but it is very very very hard to imagine
putting it to technological use why
because you can't touch it
you can't manipulate it it's not
if it if you could it would be around us
it would be here on earth and you can
find it fairly easily dark matter
doesn't interact with ordinary matter
and that's not a feature you want in a
bomb like if you're going to make a bomb
you want it to interact with ordinary
matter in a fairly dramatic way
likewise for everybody in quantum
mechanics you know it's just quantum
mechanics the predictions for the real
world are exactly those of quantum
mechanics so it doesn't really give you
anything new that that insight doesn't
give you any technological handle
of course that could be wrong it's
possible that there is something that is
unanticipated that will be a future
physical
understanding but and that's always true
i mean that's sort of a mindless cheap
thing to say the non-trivial thing to
appreciate is how fundamental physics
has passed this threshold of really
understanding the world around us and
therefore the low-hanging fruit
has been picked when it comes to
technology even when it comes to like
modern you know speculative technologies
like high temperature superconductors or
quantum computers or things like that
those are still based on known physics
they're not making taking advantage of
new physics so i completely think that
there will be all sorts of surprising
new technologies i just would not be
surprised if they were not based on
physics that we haven't yet developed
fundamental physics that we haven't yet
discovered
bob weinman says as i recall feynman had
a very low opinion of philosophy if you
had the opportunity to try to get him to
change his mind how would you begin
well i mean the short answer here is
that i wouldn't like i don't care
lots of people out there who have a low
opinion of philosophy there's lots of
people out there of low opinions of
physics or of other things you know let
them live their lives as long as they're
not bothering me uh if they start
bothering me then it's a different thing
the the section of people who matter for
a question like this are not those who
just say
i have a low opinion of x it's those who
say i think my opinion of x is low but
i'm not sure explain to me why i should
have a better opinion then that's a
person you can talk to right that's a
person who you can have a dialogue with
they're asking a question they're
interested you know once people's minds
are closed then forget about it you know
move on to more greener pastures right
i think it's a pretty easy if you did
have if if feynman or someone said look
why do you care about this stuff i'm
sincerely interested in it all you have
to do is read feynman's books to see
whole bunches of philosophy right it's
not that hard he might also at the same
time be talking out the other side of
his mouth and poo poo philosophy but he
was doing it all along he wrote a book
called the character of physical law
how much more philosophical can you get
than that
and he was really good at it too you
know when he if you read the feynman
lectures on physics you'll read a very
clear uh statement of what we would now
call the boltzmann brain problem the
need for low entropy initial condition
near the big bang which many other
people did not appreciate and what i
would point out to him is that the
people who do appreciate it now do so
largely although not exclusively but
largely due to the efforts of
philosophers not the efforts of
physicists
there is a role for sitting and thinking
carefully about the underlying logical
conceptual structure of your physical
theories and i don't think that's a
difficult case to make
justin bailey says if every particle is
an excitation in a quantum field can we
say there are really only 12-ish fields
in the universe that make up everything
well it depends on how you count is the
is a frustrating answer so think about
an electron right you can say so i know
where you're getting the 12-ish from um
just count the number of particles or
whatever right uh there's more than 12
even in the standard model because there
are six quarks and six leptons but then
there's also bosons right there's the
gauge bosons and they count those are
particles two so i don't know how many
there are but there's certainly more
than twelve but even if you take one of
them like the electron right when you
say there are six leptons one of those
leptons is an electron right in the
usual way of talking about the standard
model but how many fields are there that
you need to describe an electron you
might say well the electron field ah but
the electron field has a
spin up component and a spin down
component or a helicity right-handed or
and helicity left-handed if you want to
be slightly more technical about it so
there's really those two components
and you can't really completely clearly
distinguish the electron field from the
anti-electron field right when we say
there are six leptons we're
we're grouping together particles and
they're anti-particles so mathematically
the field that describes electrons comes
with four components which you can think
about as spinning clockwise spinning
counterclockwise electrons and positrons
two times two is four okay likewise for
quarks they have the same kind of story
except they also come in three colors
right so there's a whole bunch of fields
but then it depends on how you count and
there's no right wray or wrong way of
counting when you have a vector pointing
in space like the electric field is that
one field with a vector value or is it
three fields because the vector has
three components who cares is the answer
it doesn't matter you know but but the
spirit of your question is
are there only some small number of
fields that make up everything
well you know not everything because
there could be fields that we haven't
yet discovered because they don't
interact very strongly with um the stuff
that we do have in our laboratories like
the dark matter right dark matter is
probably some excitation of some quantum
field that we just don't know which
field it is yet
so it it might be some
relatively finite number but we don't
know what that number is right now
joachim says in the spirit of the very
effective method of in order to solve a
problem imagine you have already solved
it and work your way backwards
i would like to ask you imagine you have
fixed the climate problem how did you do
it
you know i'm not i'm not an expert on
this so you shouldn't take my uh
recommendations or anything like well
you shouldn't take my ideas as
recommendations let's put it that way uh
i'm a theoretical physicist not a
climate scientist or an engineer of any
sort whatsoever but you know at the
level of theoretical physics where
everything is a spherical cow here is
the basic problem
we've had
millions of years of life on earth
creating
what we think of as fossil fuels right
oil and gas and coal and stuff like that
out of the biological organic materials
that were put underground you know over
the course of again many millions of
years
and this is a very finite resource
it's a very valuable resource because
these are complex molecules uh a feature
of
life of biological um happenings
biological organisms they create much
more complex molecules than inorganic
processes do
so and there's only a finite amount of
it not just burning but there's other
things you can do with these fossil
fuels you can make plastics and other
materials they're crucially important
for scientific research and so forth and
we are literally burning them
right this very finite resource we are
literally setting a match to it and
lighting it on fire
and i get why you have to do that early
on in technological development but we
don't have to do that anymore we we can
save some of that resource which is why
even though
well which is why i'm not in favor of
burning through it faster which is a lot
of the uh strategy for you know having
fuel be cheaper and so forth dig up more
drill more have more pipelines that just
burns through our finite uh supply much
faster and if you think well it's finite
but still pretty big
you're wrong
this is that's you know the traditional
mistake yeah the oceans are very big we
can't make them dirty right that's not
really true we can do it if given a few
years so i would not have any fossil
fuel burned at all if you're thinking
about the ultimate solution to this
problem stop burning fossil fuels
do other things what are the other
things you know i don't know some
combination of renewable energies fusion
nuclear power whatever it is again there
are difficult technological engineering
problems that i'm not an expert
on so
um that's a long-term solution right
that is not a short-term solution um in
the short term we have to have a path to
get there from here one simple thing is
just to you know shift from
using
[Music]
machines that burn fossil fuels to using
machines that run on electricity uh put
a lot more technological development
into batteries and electrical power
generation etc having said all that
there's also the entirely different
possibility of cleaning up the
atmosphere right if it's really climate
change in particular that you care about
you can imagine
again it's easy to imagine it's hard to
build but you can imagine all sorts of
either chemical or biological ways to
remove
hydrocarbons or whatever from the
atmosphere
that could very well help i don't know
what the prospects are of for that i'm
again not an expert it does not solve
the problem that uh we have a finite
amount of fossil fuels here on earth
that we're burning through like crazy so
i'm all in favor of trying to imagine
technologies and create them that would
clean up the atmosphere but if we just
keep burning our oil and gas and coal
that will not be by itself a solution
sid huff says it seems that most
theoretical physicists believe that
gravity is fundamentally a quantum
phenomenon but no one has actually
figured it out fully is it possible that
gravity cannot in fact be quantized what
would the
implication be for the standard model
well
as i've said before any question that
begins is it possible the answer is
almost always yes sure it's possible
that gravity cannot be quantized um i
mean there's a very trivial sense in
which i think that gravity is not the
thing that should be quantized you
should have a quantum mechanical
understanding of nature from which
gravity emerges but i think that's not
what you're what you're pointing at
probably what you're imagining is
gravity which we think of as the
curvature of space-time post-einstein uh
gravity is the curvature of a classical
space-time and quantum mechanical things
happen within that space-time that's
what we call semi-classical gravity
right if you imagine you keep space-time
classical and have quantum mechanical
things going on inside it
the question is maybe is that enough
could we get by with a purely classical
space time and only have matter be
quantum but living in that classical
space time and the there's plenty of
reasons why the answer is almost
certainly not you never know for sure
you know in physics that's how it goes
some brilliant person might be able to
find out how to do it
but basically the answer the it doesn't
seem to make sense it doesn't seem to
map onto how we think about gravity
working so the classic example is
do a quantum mechanical experiment
where you split a wave function into two
different pieces and
use that to take the actually create
something where the wave function of
something big and macroscopic with a
gravitational field is literally in two
different places okay this is actually
it's easy to do in a cheap way it's hard
to do it carefully what i mean by that
is i could easily just you know measure
some spin and then move a bowling ball
left or right depending on what
measurement outcome i got but then if
you believe that wave functions really
collapsed and so forth you wouldn't
believe that the bowling ball itself was
in a superposition so what you would
really need to do to do it completely
carefully is
have an experiment where the wave
function of the bowling ball was not
interacting with that the outside world
was not measured in any way and yet was
separated into two different locations
in space and then measure the
gravitational field of the bowling ball
where does it point does it point to in
between where the two pieces of the
bowling ball and the superposition are
or
does measuring the gravitational field
cause the wave function to collapse in
some way
again we don't know what the right
answer would be but the rough feeling is
that that whole picture doesn't make
sense
the all of our familiarity with gravity
comes from situations where the
gravitating objects
have specific macroscopic locations it's
hard to imagine what to do if your
gravitating objects didn't have large
macroscopic locations specific
macroscopic locations right if your
gravity was classical how does it
respond to quantum mechanical matter
again i'm not saying that it's
impossible to imagine but it'd be very
very different than anything that we
have in physics today and it'll be hard
to figure out how to make it work
p walder says in your recent mind chat
discussion mind chat different podcast
than mindscape here but i was on a mind
chat with philip gough keith frankish
and barry lower so
the question is an issue was raised
regarding whether physics acts
differently in the brain as compared to
lab-based environments in that
discussion locality was identified as a
principle that might prohibit the known
laws of physics acting differently
within the brain regardless of its
complexity in his solo follow-up podcast
philip insisted that he would not expect
strong emergence to be present in
lab-based particle experiments because
the environment was not a complex one
and these lab-based observations could
not exclude the idea that strong
emergence could be present in the brain
due to its inherent complexity could you
comment on this
sure you know philip who i've had on the
podcast before philip gough
is a pan psychist and he doesn't believe
that physics all by itself is going to
be enough to explain consciousness which
is fine and i give philip enormous
credit for
engaging with people who disagree with
him about that but he just doesn't
understand physics very well that's okay
i don't understand neuroscience very
well i don't even understand whole
bunches of philosophy very well and so
for philip it's very easy to say ah
imagine changing the laws of physics in
some dramatic way that shows up inside a
brain but not inside a rock or inside
the large hadron collider
to those of us who understand physics
pretty well we really we appreciate how
difficult that would be again just as i
mentioned a couple of paragraphs ago you
can't say it's impossible
that's not how physics works maybe it's
possible that the behavior of an
electron is different if that electron
is embedded in a brain versus being
embedded in a rock my point is that it
is completely incompatible with
everything we know about physics
locality being the most obvious
incompatibility in the sense that the
way the laws of physics work according
to the core theory of contemporary
physics is that the electron field at
every point in space
only responds to what other fields are
doing at exactly the same point in space
it literally does not care at all
about what fields are doing elsewhere
except insofar as they help determine
what the other fields are doing at that
same point in space that is just a
bedrock feature of quantum field theory
that's what quantum field theory is in
some very real sense so you're perfectly
allowed to say well maybe it's not like
that in a brain
now number one there's zero motivation
in physics to do that all of your
motivation is from philosophical thought
experiments
and in my mind the you know fundamental
physics understanding is enormously more
sophisticated than the philosophical
thought experiments are so i trust them
much more
but the other is that as soon as you
let's put it this way you can't just
it's not okay to just say well maybe
let's be non-local let's just violate
that cherished principle of physics that
is completely
meaningless unless you do it unless you
write down a theory this is how physics
works you write down a model you write
down the equations
according to which you would modify
ordinary physics to allow for this sort
of non-locality and the reason why you
need to do that is not just because it
you know
makes you a bit more honest but because
almost inevitably when you do that
everything will break
everything that we know about how
physics works will stop working like
information moving faster than the speed
of light right if i can poke a field at
one point in space and instantly have a
reaction somewhere else which is what
you need if you're not being local
that's information moving faster than
the speed of light which could lead to
all sorts of bad things like how fast
does it move clearly you violated
lorenzen variants as well clearly you're
violating special relativity
the obvious implication of that would be
all sorts of experimental craziness that
would be very easily ruled out but i
can't tell you what that craziness is
until you've written down a model right
so no physicist is really going to take
this very seriously at all
finally something worth noting noting is
it gives you precisely zero progress on
the hard problem of consciousness right
once you've adapted the laws of physics
from the local form that we know and
love to some non-local form there's
still laws of physics
there's still physical stuff doing its
physical thing i don't see what the
possible motivation for breaking all the
laws of physics is to make absolutely no
difference to the problem that you're
trying to approach that would be my
answer
j m autobot says
i'm trying to better understand how the
universe has a shape i sometimes read
that the universe might have pinched off
a larger universe like a drop from a
glass of water or that universes might
be like bubbles of soap maybe even
colliding in the past
then i realized then i read how our
universe seems flat by our best
measurements can you help me understand
how the universe can be both bubble like
and flat especially if it is infinite
thanks
um sure the answer is we don't know what
the shape of the universe is it's
extremely possible again we don't know
but it's extremely possible that the
shape of the universe is just wildly
different from place to place that it
has no simple form like flat or
spherical or anything like that those
are all simple ideas that you can
propose and think about but there's no
empirical evidence for it the empirical
evidence is that our three-dimensional
space within our observable universe is
spatially pretty flat
okay but we also know
with with very very high confidence that
that's not the whole universe the
universe continues beyond what we can
see because we can only see back a
certain time to the big bang right
it's conceivable that literally just now
we're seeing the edge of our universe
but there's zero reason to expect that
it's much more likely the universe
continues on
maybe it continues on
keeping flat
that's possible
maybe even though our universe looks
flat to us the three-dimensional
universe in which we live the
three-dimensional space maybe it looks
flat but just because we're only seeing
a really tiny part of it just like your
yard could look flat even though the
earth is round right maybe the universe
is like that and the universe looks flat
to us but is curved on larger scales
furthermore you know all these words and
whatever bubbles and bubbles of soap
colliding and so forth these are all
kind of metaphorical colorful things
that people put forward you got to be
careful with what you mean
these colliding bubbles that people are
talking about what is colliding is the
edge of the bubble
so it's very possible that our universe
is inside
our three-dimensional universe is inside
some two-dimensional bubble which will
sometimes someday collide with the
boundary of another three-dimensional
region of space that is also a
two-dimensional bubble
we have no idea i mean we have we have
speculations along these lines it may or
may not be true but that's the edge that
would be the edge of our region of space
that would not be the region of space
itself so keep your wits about you you
know and and be very careful when people
are talking about this stuff to try to
distinguish what we have evidence for
from what we are speculating about it's
fine to speculate i do it all the time
but be clear when you're speculating
versus when you're talking about things
we actually have evidence for
an onion has a priority question and the
priority question is in the form of a
poem which i will i guess i will read
the reductio ab ad absurdum of the
botanical project in the field of
insanity strikes an elegiac note
conjectured latent variables roam unseen
even in corridors snared and prowled for
dreaming till each flash or burst be an
assigned edge the same or like as are to
nip clouds in scud
winds of unfortunate gusts and uncalf us
for the straying poles one day the basic
unit will no longer be absent a fine
mesh fence and pure tender quartering
veins no nodes barred
there's a question mark at the end of
that i have no idea what the question is
so i will take my recitation of the poem
as fulfilling the promise of the
priority question there thank you for
your poem onion
liam mccarty says
if i understand your mad dog ever ready
is evertonism approach correctly your
hypothesis is that the universe is
exactly a vector in hilbert's space and
your goal is to derive all known physics
from a spectrum of the hamiltonian i'm
curious to how you think about time from
this perspective it is is it fundamental
or somehow emergent well the short
answer is we think of time as
fundamental but it's not because we have
some conviction that time is fundamental
it's just because you know one step at a
time
we're trying to make sense of some very
difficult problems where experiment is
not being much of a guide and we have to
you know use our principles and our
theorizing etc so i'm in favor of making
as few wild leaps into the unknown as at
a time as possible so it is completely
possible in my mind that time might be
time might be emergent not fundamental
whatever but that seems to be
according to everything i know
a different question than whether space
is fundamental or emerging quantum
mechanics and quantum gravity really
seem to treat
time and space differently now obviously
our best classical theory of gravity is
einstein's general theory of relativity
where space and time are combined to
make space space-time so that is
something to be kept in mind when one is
trying to go from the quantum theory of
gravity to classical space-time but it's
not any kind of
immovable obstacle in the road it's just
an issue you'll have to keep thinking
about as the future goes as you develop
the theory more and more in the future
tim giannitzos says in computer science
space and time are considered two
resources that a computer uses to make a
computation however the third resource
is randomness
no algorithm can actually manufacture
its own randomness if there is true
randomness it is always mined from the
physical world
space and time are associated into a
manifold called space-time are there
theories that incorporate randomness
somehow as another component of this
manifold
i think that this is an intriguing
question that i don't know a simple glib
answer to because i'm not exactly sure
what it would mean to incorporate
randomness in this sense
there certainly are theories of quantum
mechanics which are truly random which
which think of the evolution of the wave
function as something that has a
completely stochastic component
i'm not sure what i guess i'm not sure
about is the extent to which this should
be considered a resource because
the universe is not really doing a
computation right the universe doesn't
have an answer that we're looking for
um in any obvious sense
but
maybe there is a role for that i'm just
not sure how to
analogize it to what computer scientists
think about so i know that was a very
unsatisfying answer uh but that's the
best i can do what i want to do is
tackle the next couple of questions i'm
going to group some other questions
together because they're along a similar
lines as to tim's question sufficiently
different i didn't want to group it
together but um with a similar
set of words appearing in them so three
questions to be grouped together roland
person says
if everything that will ever happen can
be predicted by deterministic laws of
physics how can entropy increase
wouldn't it mean that everything that
will happen was already encoded in the
initial state of the universe i read
some argument that if quantum mechanics
had some truly random probabilities in
it
then that could be a source of actual
new information that could increase
entropy in this interpretation the
future would not be predictable
douglas de young says assuming many
worlds from the point of view of
maxwell's demon is the shannon entropy
the total information content of the
universe static
i imagine a universe where there is a
momentary state and there are laws that
then process the state into subsequent
states but do not increase the shannon
entropy this somehow seems at odds with
such an informationally rich universe we
live in
and then rob griber says does an
ever-writing interpretation of quantum
mechanics suggest that as the universe
approaches an era of proton decay in the
distant future there will be fewer
worlds created that is are there fewer
interactions that create wave function
collapses as the entropy progresses or
complexity declines is this another way
of saying that as entropy increases
complexity increases then declines so
what i take to be the common thread of
these questions is that
the way the universe
explores the space of possibilities
is a little bit different if the
evolution of the universe has a random
component to it
so if you think about hypothetically
a set of laws of physics that were
completely deterministic so just to
answer the many worlds aspect of this in
many worlds of course
the underlying equation is the
schrodinger equation which is completely
deterministic but observers don't see
determinist deterministic evolution in
many worlds they better not because
experimental evidence for quantum
mechanics includes randomness right and
that's exactly what many worlds predicts
it predicts that people on branches will
see what are effectively random
unpredictable processes or at least
processes that are predictable only up
to the born rule for the probabilities
of seeing things happen so in quantum
mechanics
forgetting about the fact that the wave
function of the universe evolves
deterministically
individuals see random events
and i think that this does count as sort
of
giving the universe a little extra oomph
in terms of exploring the space of
possibilities if the universe were
completely deterministic to go back to
what i started saying if there were
completely deterministic rules not only
for the wave function of the universe
but as seen by observers
then to douglas's question
everything that ever happened in the
history of the universe would be encoded
in the initial state right the initial
state would be in principle to laplace's
demon etc able to exactly predict what
happens in the future and therefore it
has all that information is in it so if
you just calculated the shannon entropy
in the most
in the most naive way it would be a
constant it would not increase because
the shannon entropy tells you how much
information you have about the universe
now none of us
is laplace's demon or maxwell's demon or
any of those demons so we don't have
that information but in principle it
would be there okay
when people talk about the entropy of
the universe increasing they're not
talking about the shannon entropy there
are different notions of entropy they're
talking about the thermodynamic entropy
or the boltzmann entropy that is to say
imagine the microstate of the universe
there are many macroscopic
configurations that have the same
microstates associated with them and as
time goes on we move from macro states
where there's only a small number of
microstates to macro states where there
are large numbers of of microstates
associated with them so the reason why
you can reconcile the increase of that
kind of entropy
with the constancy of the shannon
entropy
is that even in the current macro state
of the universe which has a larger
boltzmann or thermodynamic entropy than
the early time does
there is something we know
about the current state of the universe
over and above its current macro state
namely that it came from a low entropy
past
that extra fact that extra piece of
information we know
tells us that the actual microstate of
the current universe is living in a tiny
tiny tiny subset of all the possible
microstates compatible with our
macroscopic information of only the
current configuration okay
anyway so
for all intents and purposes um
information is not really conserved
because we don't keep track of all those
things and quantum mechanics does jiggle
things around so
it no longer is true in quantum
mechanics that if you told me the exact
initial state of the universe i would
predict what observers would see in the
future right
now ultimately to get to rob's question
they would all see the same thing
because all of the worlds will
eventually equilibrate right the space
expands stars decay away
in the different worlds
stars and galaxies are located at
different places
different locations in space but
ultimately the stars go away they fall
into black holes the black holes
evaporate so ultimately they go to the
same equilibrium state this is exactly
the same as saying that if you put a
drop of food dye in a glass of water
as it is beginning to fill the glass of
water each path that it takes if you do
it many times in a row will be different
right the individual swirls of
complexity as the ink and the water
mixed together will be different if you
do it twice in a row but the eventual
final state is the same right and so
entropy increasing is exactly to answer
rob's question
driving this initial increase in
complexity and then diminishment in
complexity
uh i think i answered roland's question
just to be perfectly clear about it um
in some sense there is new information
there
you could imagine a classical world you
know
let's put it this way
infinity is very big
and in classical mechanics the position
of a single particle is given by a real
number that's an infinite amount of
information so
if you had 10 to the 80th atoms like we
have in our observable universe in a
classical deterministic universe you
could still put an enormous amount of
information into the initial state okay
so it's not that you can't fit it in
there classically you need quantum
mechanics the new thing is the following
in quantum mechanics you can imagine
that the initial state is truly low
information
information in the sense that it doesn't
take a lot of information to specify the
initial state so classically to specify
the initial state of 10 to the 80th
particles is exactly as easy or
difficult as but as specifying the final
state of 10 to the 80th particles that
information is conserved but in quantum
mechanics because of branching
you can imagine that the initial state
of the universe is very very simple i
mean that's literally what harlow and
hawking did when they talk about the
wave function of the universe they have
a really really simple initial quantum
state for the universe
and then because of branching that
initial simplicity is broken up and the
combination of everything is simple but
the individual roots that are taken by
pads are very complicated just as i can
take you know a very simple circular
uh plate right a circular piece of wood
and i can cut it using a jigsaw into
many different complicated looking
shapes the many different complicated
shapes fit together to make something
simple that's exactly what many worlds
does from a simple initial quantum state
of the universe
gillis 15 says i read about your pending
move to baltimore does that mean you
will no longer teach at the santa fe
institute additionally did you have a
chance to tour los alamos if so what did
you think i'm a native new mexican so it
mean the world to me if you answered
these
uh i am moving to baltimore but my
affiliation with the santa fe institute
remains what it was i will not be
teaching there because nobody teaches
there
it is not a teaching institution it is a
research institution uh my official
title there is fractal faculty which
means i spend several weeks a year a
couple months a year at santa fe and i'm
going to continue to do that in fact i'm
going to go in august i will be there uh
i have once been to los alamos to give a
talk but that was a long time ago and i
couldn't really tell you much about it
but i love santa fe love new mexico it's
a great place to visit that's one of the
reasons why i wanted this uh affiliation
with them
ken wolfe says for a while i've been
thinking about the utility of near-death
experiences as a means of advancement to
new level levels of sophistication
as an example our species has
experienced blah my talking is not very
good today
as a as an example our species has
experienced at least one near extinction
event when we were reduced to a few
thousand individuals as another the more
i read about long-lived civilizations
like the roman civilization the more
their history looks like a series of
near-collapse experiences my question is
have you come across anything in your
intellectual pursuits or your personal
life that suggests a link between
near-death experiences and opportunities
for development
well um short answer no
if you're talking about actual
academic work on this subject i would
recommend
not
calling what you're referring to
near-death experiences because there's a
whole
community of people who study near-death
experiences uh in order to prove the
existence of life after death actual
human beings coming close to death and
seeing heaven or god or their relatives
or whatever that's that's what most
people think of when you say near-death
experience uh so i don't think you have
that in mind i mean of course there is
some general vague feeling that nothing
focuses the mind like a hanging right
like being in extreme circumstances
forces you to think in creative ways
right if everything is comfortable if
you're near equilibrium then you can
sort of get along making the same slight
mistakes that you've been making a long
time
and being in dramatic circumstances
makes you think
um having said that i'm not in favor of
near-collapse experiences either as a
person or as a civilization uh in part
because of survivorship bias right
you say things like or we perceive that
oh you know this person or this society
or this institution went through a
really bad period and came out better
the other side therefore really bad
periods are good for you but often
really bad periods lead to you not
coming out the other side right the risk
of not surviving is much
more when you're near collapse
so i think that if you were to do a cost
benefit analysis i would not be in favor
of many
of frequent near-collapse experiences
that would be my guess
joshua hillerup says i've just had a
multi-day power outage here in canada
where lots of people in my area still
don't have power my question is what
sort of preparation do you have at your
home for something like that well you
know my home is changing as we mentioned
above here right now i'm in los angeles
where there is a special set of
challenges for long-term um
well i shouldn't say long term rare but
severe events right like an earthquake
or a fire or something like that
mudslides who knows power outages uh so
yeah like many los angeles folks
southern california folks we have an
earthquake kit with food basic medical
supplies um some simple
lighting and masks and warm blankets and
things like that
the
main problem if we had a severe
earthquake here in l.a would be a loss
of power and water for some period of
time
so no one ever has enough water we do
have some water but uh everything i've
read about these things says says you
never have enough water because you
forget how much water you go through in
a day so we try to have many gallons of
water but probably not enough um yeah so
the basics moving to baltimore of course
northeast corridor
it's a different set of worries
earthquakes not a major worry but now
you have hurricanes not to mention just
other severe weather events so we'll be
bringing our earthquake kit with us a
lot of overlap between what you need an
earthquake and what you need in a
hurricane we're not uh looking for
places right on the water so we're
hopefully not in danger of flooding but
that will depend on where we live who
knows
joe says if you couldn't get paid to do
the various things you do now what would
you do instead to earn a living oh wait
i'm sorry i wanted to continue with
joshua's quest and say one other thing
about the emergency preparations which
is that it's a sort of small personal
version of a larger societal question
about how to prepare
for
rare but extreme occurrences right
everything in our training
our biology uh sets us up to survive for
things that are likely to happen on our
lifespan time scale right things that
happen once every thousand years are
very very hard to plan for or prepare
for but we should and i don't have any
deep thoughts about that but maybe think
about it when you ask the question um
you know we're we're very good at
preparing for things that happen every
every week or even every year with high
probability we're not very good at
planning for things that happen once
every 10 years or even things that would
happen once every 100 years but if they
did they'd be devastating so i am a
believer i think this was a question
that was asked in an earlier ama but i
am a believer in preparing for those
kinds of things and also in appreciating
that it's difficult to put precisely the
right amount of effort into preparing
for something like that you don't want
to be too alarmist about it but you
don't want you don't want to ignore it
either
anyway okay so joe's question was if you
couldn't get paid to do the various
things you do now what would you do
instead to earn a living this is a very
hard question because the various things
i do now are kind of multifaceted right
so everything i like doing whether it's
teaching or research or writing or
speaking or talking to interesting
people these are the things i like to do
the most and my current uh job i've
managed through uh hard work it took me
a while but i've managed to carve out a
living where i do a little bit of all of
those things so i'm not trying to
interpret the question like if i would
have to give up on all of those things
i'd be in trouble
you know if i'm not allowed to write or
speak or teach or do research for a
living hmm it's not a lot it's not a lot
that i'm both competent at and uh could
earn a living doing i mean i could
imagine you know being a different kind
of professor but that's probably not
what you have in mind i can also imagine
just being
a writer of some sort even a fiction
writer i have no
way of claiming that i'd be any good at
that but because i haven't really done
it with any level of seriousness but
that's something i could imagine doing
and enjoying
caliban carol asks i'm sure that's a
pseudonym because i know caliban and he
is not a patreon supporter believe me
uh if you were to witness a tremendously
unlikely event say your cat quantum
tunneling through a wall
and had no reason to doubt your mental
faculties would you tell others about
this experience at the risk of sounding
delusional or would you keep it to
yourself
well i think that if it were a
sufficiently unlikely event it would be
a much more likely explanation that i
miss
experienced something right either i was
hallucinating or
you know something wrong with my brain
having a stroke or something like that
this is the much higher credence that i
misunderstood what was happening than
literally the cat going through a wall
so i would go to get a checkup or
something like that i would not just
hide it and keep it to myself you know
if it's reproducible that's an entirely
different question right because if
something unlikely happens once
that's one thing
if something unlikely happens several
times in a row then it's not really
unlikely is it something is making it
happen and that would absolutely be a
reason to tell other people about it
richard graf says if i assume there are
multiple dark matter particles what if
anything would prevent the existence of
an entire dark matter universe with
structures similar to galaxies solar
systems planets and perhaps even life
that would still remain undetectable to
us
well the short answer there is that it's
dark in the dark matter and what we mean
by that is roughly speaking that it
doesn't interact or it interacts only
very very weakly if dark matter
interacted strongly
even as strongly as ordinary matter does
that's what we don't mean necessarily
the strong interactions but if dark
matter interacted
with the same with itself with other
dark matter particles with the same um
strength as good old ordinary
electromagnetism it would clump and form
structures pretty easily but the point
is that
we've looked at the universe
we know more or less what the dark
matter distribution is and it's not very
clumpy at all it's exactly what you'd
expect for what is essentially a
collisionless
particle
so there's good reason to think that
there's not a lot of interesting
interactions in the dark matter sector
so there are two exceptions to that one
is that people have occasionally floated
the idea the dark matter particles do
occasionally bump into each other and
that helps explain this or that feature
of the large-scale structure of galaxies
or the satellites around ordinary
galaxies and things like that so far
those ideas although they're fascinating
and would be great if they were true
they haven't quite panned out
there are discrepancies out there
between our theoretical models of the
formation of structure in the universe
and what we observe so in the podcast
episode with priya natarajan we talked
about some of those discrepancies the
problem is that mostly not 100
but mostly those discrepancies seem to
occur in exactly the regimes where it's
hard to predict what the standard model
would actually
imply
so people have suggested changing the
physics of dark matter to fix those
problems but often the problems just go
away when you look at them more closely
so that's one caveat the other caveat is
i did once ask myself the sort of the
scientific version of this question
in particular
could there be an electromagnetic
kind of force between the dark matter
particles so when other people do
strongly interacting dark matter or
whatever they really mean a short range
force right the two dark matter
particles come together scatter
inelastically off of each other so sorry
elastically off of each other they're
just like billiard balls
and that sort of exchanges some of their
momentum but could you have a long range
force
between the dark matter particles
something like electromagnetism right
let's call it dark electromagnetism
so obviously for the reasons i just gave
it can't be exactly like
electromagnetism because it would clump
very easily but remember or for that
matter particles would annihilate like
protons and antiprotons would just
annihilate if there were dark particles
and dark anti-particles and they were
both charged you would expect them to
annihilate into dark photons
but anyway there is a free parameter in
electromagnetism called the fine
structure constant which has in our
universe a value of about 1 over 137
so there's the obvious possibility that
you just decrease that number to make
the interactions weaker right to make
the electromagnetic the dark
electromagnetic strength less noticeable
than ordinary electromagnetism
so
i did this i you know i did the science
paper with uh collaborators lottie
ackerman matthew buckley mark
kaminkowski
matthew is now faculty at rutgers and
mark is now at johns hopkins where i'm
going to be joining him and we'll have
an office down the hallway from from
mark kamikowski and so we wrote a paper
on dark matter and dark radiation right
dark electromagnetism and the
fascinating thing to notice that we
noticed is that it's easier than you
think to get away with having dark
electromagnetism because as long as you
make the dark fine structure constant a
little bit lower you know maybe a factor
of 10 smaller than the ordinary fine
structure constant
and you make the dark matter particles
heavier than ordinary protons and
neutrons the dark matter particles might
be a hundred or a thousand
uh times the mass of the proton then
there aren't that many dark matter
particles and they don't interact that
strongly with each other and as a result
they don't really annihilate because
they don't bump into each other that
often the annihilation rate becomes
fairly small
um so you can get away with it you can
get the right relic abundance it's much
like a weekly interacting massive
particle except
rather than interact through the weak
interactions it interacts through this
new dark electromagnetism which is a
long-range force
the bad news is that long-range forces
have their own energy fields right the
electric field of the magnetic field in
our ordinary case
so
there is an instability where you can
make dark magnetic fields
and dark magnetic fields might
dramatically warp the
formation of large-scale structure so we
finished the paper by saying that
there's this big caveat here that might
ruin the whole idea and we also said at
the very end of the paper you know
once you've done this so basically what
we were proposing was the dark matter
equivalent of protons and antiprotons
heavier versions of those
if you also had
dark electrons and dark positrons then
you could imagine dark atoms right and
they could be electrically neutral and
stop the instability to make dark
magnetic fields so we mentioned that and
other people have since followed up on
that including david kaplan another uh
future colleague of mine a particle
physicist at johns hopkins so they've
written papers about dark atoms and and
again
interestingly there is room for that uh
you can imagine it happening you gotta
you gotta really jump through some hoops
it's not the most natural thing in the
world uh but you can imagine it
happening
um it has to be more weakly interacting
than ordinary matter or you would have
easily
seen the dark planets dark galaxies etc
which we don't see but it's a it's a
possibility even if there's no strong
motivation for it it is absolutely
something that is interesting and we
should look at probably not
dark life forms or anything like that
because the force has to be fairly weak
but i'm not completely convinced i'm not
allowed to say that so who knows
brendan says i'm always impressed with
the vast vocabulary you articulate
during your podcast was there ever a
time you focused on building up your
vocabulary specifically or did it come
naturally by reading papers writing
books talking with people listening to
lectures etc um definitely the latter
i've never
tried very hard to build up my
vocabulary but i've always loved words
loved reading loved talking and you know
i try to do so in a fairly conscious way
so it's not just that i talk and write
but i think about
talking and writing while i do it so
that just tends to very naturally build
up your vocabulary i don't think my
vocabulary is all that impressive
honestly but i i appreciate the
compliment brendan thank you
preston justice says if you could learn
any other language instantly with
native-like proficiency but only one
which would you choose and why so i'm
going to weasel out i'm going to give
you two different possible answers to
this one if it were purely for reasons
of personal pleasure i think it would be
french
because france is the country that i
love to visit the most and eat the food
at and sit at the cafes and have some
coffee and whatever but i don't speak a
word of french maybe ten words um i can
get around but probably not enjoy things
nearly as much as i would if i were a
fluent speaker
if instead of personal pleasure reasons
we were thinking of sort of geopolitical
import reasons then clearly you'd want
to learn mandarin right or some variety
of chinese because china is
[Music]
incredibly important country in the
world right now uh growing ever more
important and it's one that i think that
a lot of english speakers don't
understand very well in part because
they're not chinese speakers i think
that would be uh really good to have
more people who actually understood
chinese in the world there's a lot more
chinese people who understand english
than there are americans who understand
chinese
lewis b says i've heard it said that
inside the event horizon time and space
switch roles and this is usually
followed by a statement of the form
inside a black hole you can know easier
no more easily avoid traveling to the
singularity then out here you can avoid
traveling to tomorrow the second
statement gives a reasonably intuitive
sense in which a point in space becomes
a bit like a point in time but is there
any analogous sense in which time
becomes a bit like space inside a black
hole can i freely move left and right in
time
no you cannot and the reason why is
because the initial statement
inside the event horizon time and space
switch roles is complete nonsense
it is entirely hilariously wrong i know
you've heard it before
there's a reason why people say it and
there's sort of more and less
respectable reasons why people say it
but the real reason why people are
inspired to say it in the first place is
because if you start doing the most
naive thing outside of a black hole and
so you set up coordinates to try to
describe your
black hole space time right
mr short shield did this carl short
shield when he first invented the short
shield metric for a black hole so you
have x or r you know the radial
coordinate theta and phi r theta and phi
spherical coordinates and then you have
t the time coordinate and then you just
naively without thinking very hard
extend those coordinates inside the
horizon of a black hole what happens is
the r-coordinate
becomes time-like and the t-coordinate
becomes space-like
that's a true fact but it's also a
physically completely irrelevant fact it
has absolutely nothing to do with time
and space switching roles it's just a
statement about what coordinates we put
on time and space inside the event
horizon the coordinate that used to be
the radial coordinate in space is now
the time coordinate and the time in the
coordinate that used to be the time
chord is now the space coordinate but
there's still space and time if you were
inside the event horizon you wouldn't
even notice that you were inside the
event horizon there would be time and
there would be space
and you could move in space in three
different directions you move in time
only in one just like always
now the statement that the singularity
is in the future not to the left is
completely true
the singularity is in the future but
that just means not that there is some
analogy between points in space and
points in time it just means a
singularity is not a point in space
it's a moment of time full stop now the
singularity is at r equals zero
but r is a coordinate that gives you the
time-like direction so r equals zero is
a moment in time it's in your future
it's not at the center of a black hole
that's the the truth of it you can take
that to the bank
james brown says priority question i
read your book something deeply hidden
twice and listen to it as well
my question is what is your estimate of
the number of times the wave function of
the universe has split or what is its
estimated splitting rate
so the short answer is no one has any
idea no one even has any idea whether
the question makes sense because we
don't know whether hilbert space the
space of all possible quantum wave
functions is infinite dimensional or
finite dimensional so forget about real
numbers actual
values we don't even know if it's finite
or infinite
if the hilbert space of the universe is
infinite dimensional then splitting is a
continuous process
it's like asking how many numbers are
there between point one and point two
right well there's an infinite number
that's still
there's an infinite number between point
one and point two and there's still only
tenth
as many numbers as there are between
zero and one right both of those
statements are true at the same time
if helper space is infinite dimensional
branching splitting is just happening
all the time and you can't talk about
how many branches there are it's just a
meaningless concept now if it's finite
dimensional which i think is very
plausible
then
there is some number which is how often
it splits but that number depends on
details about quantum gravity which we
have no idea about honestly um it
doesn't just depend on details of
quantum gravity it depends on details of
how we divide up
the hilbert space of the universe into
systems and environments and things like
that okay
so it's just not a very well-defined
question
no matter how you slice it but one way
or the other the answer is a lot
it splits very very often let's just put
it that way
all right i'm going to group two
questions together
one is from phil who says
imagine you were handed a program by an
artificial intelligence that can
perfectly predict any experimental
outcome not a black box you're allowed
to look at the source code but the
program is so extremely low level or
complicated that you can't figure out
how anything we see emerges over it
would you consider physics solved at
that point
and then varun nara simhachar says have
you tried to reflect on what constitutes
an explanatory or satisfactory theory
even just to your own sensibilities from
any given state of science what factors
determine the epistemic directions in
which you continue to ask questions so
let me answer varun's question first
even though it came second um
i don't know is the short answer it's
always my favorite answer here at the
amas to say that i don't know
it's a you know it when you see it kind
of situation what counts as a good
explanation what counts as a
satisfactory theory
um
however let me say two slightly more
detailed things
one is
that you might not
you can try ahead of time to
imagine some criteria for what counts as
an explanation or satisfactory or
whatever but nature might not care
okay
so
it's i'm always suspicious of attempts
to say this is what counts as an
explanation and then demand that nature
live up to that and nature doesn't
always work that way and so
the reality of scientific practice is
much more a give and take figure it out
as you go kind of thing we're trying to
understand how nature works we have some
theories that are good some are bad and
we try to make them better and you know
that's that's what it is and i think
that's the right thing that it should be
rather than deciding ahead of time uh on
how things should be having said that
the other thing that i wanted to say is
that
given the progress of science it is
still very interesting uh to try to be
more careful than we are about you know
it when you see it in terms of
explanatory power
um some theories are more explanatory
than others and in different senses than
others so this is a perfectly legitimate
thing to try to do within the philosophy
of science
so what i'm trying to uh to argue
against doing or at least you know raise
a red flag about doing is deciding ahead
of time what counts as explanatory
deciding after the fact why a certain
theory is explanatory is a perfectly
sensible thing to do
and then to phil's question you know no
i would not count that as explanatory at
all to have a black box and consider
physics solved i've actually
mentioned this thought experiment myself
before what that would count as a black
box that could predict any experimental
outcome
that's not a theory of the universe
that's just an experiment generator
right so you can just ask it any
question you want like if i collided two
particles together with a certain
velocity or whatever what would come out
with what probabilities you don't need
to build particle accelerators anymore
you don't need to have telescopes and so
forth that's what that would be very
very useful for but an explanation
that a theoretical physicist would want
is a simple
compact way of compressing all of those
outcomes into an understandable theory
and so the box would help you develop
that but it would not count as that all
by itself
vincent ohm says should science and
physics in particular always strive for
explaining the underlying mechanisms and
inner workings of the world at different
scales is that even possible for the
quantum world or should we just take the
equations as a starting point and not
ask what is underlying these equations
for instance the many worlds theory is
deduced from the quantum mechanics
equations but it does not explain the
mechanism by which the universe splits
or does it so this is related to the
previous two questions and that's why i
put it here but it is i didn't want to
lump it together because uh many worlds
absolutely does explain the mechanism by
which the universe splits and i knew
that was gonna you know poke my um uh i
don't know my pre-existing hot buttons
or whatever it is so i didn't want to
lump it in with the other questions but
that's the beauty that's the whole point
of many worlds is it explains everything
uh there's no extra stuff it's just
there's a wave function it evolves
according to the schrodinger equation
when does the universe split when
quantum mechanical systems that are in a
superposition become entangled with
their environment aka decoherence okay
now maybe what you mean is but you
haven't explained why the wave function
obeys the schrodinger equation sure
you can try to derive the schrodinger
equation from other principles people
talk about that but you've just invented
those other principles
you haven't derived those principles
right so i just like to say look the
schrodinger equation is the equation
that the wave function obeys and i'm not
trying to derive it or explain it that's
the bottom
until we come up with a better theory
than quantum mechanics that is the
postulate that we use to construct this
theory that we think does such a good
job of fitting the data
marco tausser says does many worlds
alter the probability you assign to
there being other intelligent life forms
in the universe for example could
intelligence occur many times throughout
the multiverse but only once or on one
planet in a typical intelligence hosting
universe
so yes i think it does and actually
maybe i should have lumped this with the
previous questions
about the emergence of complexity and
determinism and randomness etc because
this is is precisely
something where
there is a difference in how you would
think about what happens in the universe
if you believed in many worlds versus a
single single stochastic universe so
remember for agents who are living in
the universe
living in the many worlds interpretation
is exactly the same as living in the
copenhagen interpretation or whatever or
hidden variables or or what have you uh
up until the point where such
theories are not completely well defined
but you observe one universe with
essentially random quantum outcomes but
many world says that the whole ensemble
of all the branches uh exists all at one
time and so i could easily imagine i
don't know if it's true but i could
easily imagine that the chances of life
existing on any one branch of the
universe of the wave function are small
maybe even very very very small but
there's enough branches that it happens
many many times
this goes back to the idea of sampling
the space of possibilities right
quantum mechanics in many worlds with
its branching structure samples a very
diverse space of possibilities much
bigger than any one universe would be
able to sample so exactly because of
that um it is completely possible that
life is rare in the multiverse but
nevertheless happens many times because
there are so many branches
now i'm going to group couple questions
together once again a few questions
actually because this is a popular topic
after the judea pearl uh podcast
oleg ruvinsky says
in your recent excellent talk with judea
pearl you had an interesting
disagreement on entropy you brought an
example of a low entropy state as a
triangle of billiard balls set up on a
table and have a high entropy state as
all these same balls after they're hit
by the cue ball judea objected to it by
saying that the difference here the only
difference here is in the eyes of the
beholder we humans understand and
recognize triangles but we don't
recognize the pattern created by the cue
ball but that's not a substantial
difference you objected but i'm not sure
i understood your argument as to why a
triangle is indeed a low entropy state
versus some other random configuration
okay that's one question matt rappaport
says
in the judeo pearl discussion you
discuss the pool table with the balls
racked in triangle blah blah blah
if there are x possible configurations
of all the balls isn't the probability
of the triangle configuration and the
probability of the dispersed
configuration both just one over x i'm
not clear on how or why entropy has
increased
s p sheridan says i very much enjoyed
the mindscape interview with jay pearl
but i was surprised that he was not
aware of the forward arrow of time being
connected with increasing entropy as
even more perplexed that he disagreed
with you on that a person could tell
simply by watching a movie on a billiard
table if a cue ball breaking a triangle
of billiard balls is being run forward
or backward in time and it goes on but
it's basically the same question
francois varsion says is in the biggest
idea biggest ideas in the universe
episode on entropy
you mentioned that what we choose to be
macroscopically observable is not
arbitrary we cannot see all the atoms as
there isn't enough information coming
out in the photons i interpret that as
we cannot access all the information
from a given given macroscopic system
is this still true for microscopic
systems like an atom or a cubit if not
how does it work so i hope that the that
last question which is a little bit
different you can see how it's relating
to the earlier questions the earlier
questions are all about in the billiard
table example
why are we justified in saying that
having all the billiard balls cued up in
the triangle in the rack all nice and
neat is low entropy and having them
scattered around the table is high
entropy and the answer is that we
perceive them differently this is a case
where we put a coarse graining on the
space of places the billiard balls could
be if all the billy balls are next to
each other snuggled up together that's
in a different macro state than having
all the billiard balls scattered around
and it works in the boltzmannian sense
of thinking about this in terms of
entropy there are fewer ways to arrange
the billiard balls so they're all
touching each other then there are ways
of scattering the billiard balls around
the table so you might object well
but that's just because i think of it as
different and i'm choosing ahead of time
to put that particular course graining
on the set of billiard balls and the
answer is sure
you are
but guess what doing so gives you a
handle on what's happening because the
billiard table is not a closed system
if you were to just walk into a room
with a
pool table and see that all the balls
had been
are sitting on the pool table in a neat
little triangular array
you would know that it is not just a
random configuration of billiard balls
even though that configuration is just
as likely as any other configuration
there is something special about that
that makes you think aha someone racked
the billiard balls right
and
the same thing is true for much more
realistic systems i mean the of course
the billiard table is realistic there
are billiard tables in the world but
it's not a great example of entropy
because there's not that many balls
right so you can't quite see the large
end limit here when there's only you
know whatever it is 15 billiard balls on
the table uh when as opposed to like 10
to the 20 or 10 to the 30 particles in
some macroscopic collection of matter so
in the real world where we're talking
about thermodynamics and real world
systems
the difference between having all the
air molecules in one cubic centimeter in
the corner of a room versus having all
the air molecules dispersed throughout
the room is dramatic and very very
noticeable
uh and precisely because the universe
began in a very low entropy state we
nevertheless do find
stuff in low entropy configurations in
exactly this sense of the coarse
graining that you and i choose to put on
it
and that helps us understand the world
because we can talk about that and then
understand why you see ice cubes melt
and you don't see ice cubes unmelt
that's a fact about the world that we
observe and we understand it in terms of
these course grainings that we put on
the world now as francois alludes to
there are reasons why we choose some
core screenings and not others and it's
more clear in the case of big
thermodynamic systems than it is in the
case of the billiard balls because you
coarse grain based on what you see
you can see
the
ink in the water you can see the ice
cube in the glass of water right you can
see this macroscopic configuration you
can't see all the atoms and so there's
an immediate relationship between our
physical interaction with the system
and how we choose to coarse grain it now
you could perfectly well apply that to
the billiard ball example
because we have ways of thinking about
the billiard balls and communicating
about them if you say to someone the
billiard balls are all racked and ready
to be broken at the beginning of the
game you instantly know
more or less precisely the position of
the billiard balls i mean some people
might actually arrange them within the
triangle slightly differently but up to
that rearranging you know exactly what
the billiard balls are doing whereas if
someone says the billiard balls have
been broken they're scattered across the
table
you don't know the exact positions of
all the balls there are many many
microstates that correspond to that
description so there's a real physical
difference and a reason why we choose to
coarse grain in that way even though you
could coarse green in other ways you
could invent some weird set of locations
on the table and say that i will
call it low entropy if the billiard
balls are in exactly those locations and
high entropy if they're anywhere else
you could do that it would be useless
because you're never going to see the
billiard balls in those locations there
are good physical reasons why we choose
the coarse grainings that we do
okay sandro stuckey says
i've seen many explanations of
heisenberg's uncertainty principle that
goes something like this to measure the
position of a particle more precisely we
want higher resolution so we need to use
higher frequency photons which affect
the velocity of a particle more because
they have higher energy then there's a
derivation of the relationship between
position momentum by the relationship of
frequency and energy i know that the
uncertainty principle is much more
general than that and that it is
fundamental in quantum physics so is the
above explanation wrong or is it correct
but just an illustration
well it is correct it is not wrong but
it is not an explanation of the
uncertainty principle it is
one way of thinking about one of the
consequences of the uncertainty
principle but the uncertainty principle
itself does not make any reference to
measurements or observations certainly
doesn't make any reference at all to the
mechanism by which we measure things
okay the uncertainty principle is just a
statement about what possible quantum
states exist
not a statement about what happens when
we measure them
it as a consequence
of the uncertainty principle and the
nature of quantum mechanics you can
derive things like if you were to
measure the variables like position and
momentum there is no quantum state for
which you could measure them exactly or
you could predict exactly what you're
going to get for both such variables
position and momentum but even if you
chose never to measure it it would still
be true
that expressed as a superposition of
positions
or momenta there are no quantum states
that are exactly localized in position
and momentum simultaneously and in fact
the more localized any one particular
state is with respect to position the
less localized it is with respect to
momentum and vice versa that's the
uncertainty principle and it's really
just a matter of choosing different
coordinates right i mean the the
explanation that i use in something
deeply hidden and probably elsewhere
is just think about a two-dimensional
plane right with x and y-coordinates
and i can draw a vector that points 100
in the x-direction or 100 in the
y-direction nothing stops me from doing
that so these would be
states of definite x and y but then i
can also draw coordinates on that plane
that are rotated 45 degrees with respect
to the original ones right x prime and y
prime i can also draw vectors that are
completely oriented on the x prime
direction or the y prime direction what
i can't do is draw a vector that is 100
oriented on both the x and the x prime
directions at the same time because
they're rotated with respect to each
other that is the uncertainty principle
position and momentum are just two
different coordinate systems in hilbert
space and you cannot localize in them
both simultaneously
paul kent says which bass guitar model
do you own and when you do eventually
find the time which other music genres
or notable bass players will you look to
for inspiration or technique guidance
ah well i own an ibanez uh that is my
the base that i have sitting behind me
right now and as i mentioned before i've
not been playing it very much you know i
love a lot of bass players in all sorts
of different genres but i can't really
in good conscience say that i'm looking
to them for inspiration since they are
so far away from me i'm still learning
how to play scales and things like that
right um you know my favorite rock bass
players are
uh chris squire jack bruce getty lee
john entwistle is one of my absolute
favorites there's also jazz bass players
jacob pistorius and so forth charles
mingus uh is absolutely amazing um and
there's a million session players or
lesser known people who have amazing
technique who you know don't become
famous for one reason or another uh so i
i don't have you know specific
favorites uh in that
no i do have favorites i do not have
people i'm trying to emulate let's put
it that way
flying waffle oh i remember what i
wanted to do i wanted to tell you the
time i got to appear on stage with flea
of the red hot chili peppers you know
this is not a spoiler alert i don't
think but flea uh in a very adorable
circumstance is uh one of the actors on
the new obi-wan kenobi series i'm not
sure if that's a well-known fact but
again i'm not really spoiling anything
um so i recognized him as soon as i saw
him
you know he lives in la like many uh
working musicians do and i live in la
and
there was i'm not self sure exists but
there was a program called music
in pasadena which would put on
quirky
experimental musical performances for
audiences and this was years ago and uh
the gimmick in this case was to have a
rock bass player
a classical cello player
and a
theoretical physicist
get up on stage and take turns
interacting with each other in different
ways so it was me flea of the red hot
chili peppers and matt hymovitz who is a
cellist
and uh you know it was one of the very
few times
in my career of getting on stage that i
really wished i had just not gotten on
stage at all not because it wasn't fun
for me but because the real highlight of
this event was matt heimovitz the
classical cello player and flea the rock
bass player just improvising on stage
together like every second that i was up
there talking was a waste of this
precious opportunity honestly but i did
you know i got up and told a little
story about galileo with flea
uh improvising on the base behind me and
that was a lot of fun you know i i don't
think that there are any recordings of
this event but i swear i'm not lying to
you about it
flea is pretty awesome also he's a great
bass player
okay flying waffle says
you mentioned that an electron and a
positron can be assembled into
positronium something similar to a
hydrogen atom but then in what
situations does matter and antimatter
actually annihilate so
positronium annihilates
you can put positrons and electrons
together in an orbit but they don't last
very long they do annihilate for exactly
this reason positrons and electrons
combine to make a couple of photons but
it does take some time so you calculate
this is you know something that if
you're
insufficiently lucky you might be
assigned as a homework problem in a
quantum field theory course imagine that
you are in the ground state of
positronium what is the lifetime that is
to say what is the average
number of seconds before they annihilate
and it's a non-zero number but it's a
very short number positronium doesn't
last very long
the
neuropean says
you occasionally put ads into the free
podcast episodes could you give us some
background as to how this came about
do you just select from individual
offers you get in your inbox or do you
reach out to brands you like
uh is there a lot of freedom and how you
phrase the ad are you happy with adding
the occasional ad so far or does it not
make out that much of an impact compared
to patreon
so actually yeah you know the patreon
itself came about at the same time as
the ads so once the podcast came into
existence
uh i i was reached out to by an agent
who said you know i would like to
sell your podcast to a podcast network
who will put ads on it and we can all
make money
and uh that happened and i joined wonder
e wonder is my podcast network wondering
mostly does narrative kinds of podcasts
that they will eventually work into tv
shows so i am not that there's never
going to be a mindscape tv show
um but basically what wonderee does is
sell ads that we put in the podcast and
um once that started you know i thought
it would always be a good idea
um to allow listeners if they wanted to
to have ad-free versions of the podcast
so that's why i created the patreon in
the first place
in the early days of the podcast there
wasn't any and so the patreon came into
existence as a way to get the podcast
without ads and it's taken on a life of
its own uh for very good reasons which
is wonderful i still don't make as much
cash from the patreon as i do from
selling the ads uh so the ads are a
bigger income stream than the patreon is
they're comparable same order of
magnitude but the ads are definitely
bigger
i'm generally pretty happy with it you
know one of the things about the
contract that i have with wondering is i
can refuse any ads any advertiser that i
want and you'd be you'd be shocked at
how many advertisers i refuse to
advertise not because they're evil or
bad or whatever but there's a huge
number of of companies that want to
advertise health products okay so
whether it's you know diet supplements
or or whatever
and i just can't as a scientist
be seen to be endorsing these if i don't
understand them right and i don't
understand any health products
whatsoever you know as at a professional
level
so that's a huge part of the podcast ad
ecosystem and i just don't participate
in it at all
but that's okay you know i'd rather
only have ads for things that i believe
in so even things that are not
health um endorsed or health related
which i think i can you know if it's a
you know here is a suitcase company okay
i will even if i'm not familiar with the
suitcase i will check out online are
they reputable you know do they get good
reviews things like that and if they
seem to be a scam or not reputable then
i won't do it and i've turned down
advertisers for that reason also
and finally when it comes to the script
i mean they generally give you a script
and you read it uh in fact they would
like it if i improvised more if you know
i acted like uh this was just my own
words but you know i would i'm just
there's not a lot of time in the day and
so i'm very happy if they give me a
script just to read the script so i look
for some
um
sort of compromise there because i do
typically they ask that you experience
the product so like when i when i
talk about kitty litter or coffee or
whatever on the podcast i have drunk
that coffee i have uh given that kitty
litter to put in the cat box for ariel
and caliban i've tried it out and i can
say in good conscience that it is worth
doing so
uh i do have some personal experience
with essentially all these things that i
am that i am advertising so i'm
perfectly happy with the advertising you
know if people don't want it they can
join patreon right and nevertheless
a huge fraction of the people who listen
to the podcast listen to the ad version
they do not come onto patreon so that's
the choice they're making which is great
anonymous says
there are good ways to carve reality
into objects like jupiter and air force
one and bad ways like an object parts of
jupiter and bits of air force one
are there physics-y ways to think about
how i choose a good ontology like am i
using labels to minimize the lyapunov
exponent for my measurements or
maximizing information conservation or
something mathy like that
well this is a great question and a
crucially important question right i
mean this is basically the question of
emergence how do you
carve things that are made of atoms or
quantum fields or whatever into large
macroscopic objects in useful ways
and i think everyone agrees
roughly on the the the point of this
kind of carving which is that you carve
nature into ways such that when all the
information you have is information
about the chunks into which you carved
it
you are left with the ability to say
something interesting to make a
prediction for the future or to
understand what's going to happen next
or anything like that so you look for
you know the finest grained ways you can
chop things up and yet maintain some
ability to characterize the system in a
small number of bits while yet
predicting what's going to happen next
maybe up to some probabilities or
something like that but that's the
general idea however
taking this general rough idea and
making it precise turns out to be really
hard especially when
there's incomplete information about the
underlying system so like one obvious
example
that i always like to remember because
it's so obvious people can actually
understand it is the center of mass
of a celestial object right we can track
the motion of the moon and the earth and
the solar system without tracking the
positions of all of their atoms and
molecules and that's still deterministic
right not only do you know what the
earth will do but you know it
deterministically and isaac newton was
able to do this and we can predict
eclipses and things like that far far in
the future
very often that's not going to be the
case if the higher level systems are
something like a person or for that
matter a volcano or a hurricane
maybe the best we can do is some
probabilistic predictions and then you
get into a whole different
set of questions about how do you
minimize uncertainties given these
probabilities etc
so
i i
chose this question for answering
because i literally am doing this as a
research program and this is not
something i've made a lot of progress on
but i'm very very interested in reading
what other people have done and trying
to make my own little
contributions to it what is the general
theory of what emerges from what how do
you carve microscopic things into
macroscopic things i think there is no
general answer to that that i know of
right now people have suggested things i
mean we did a whole podcast with anil
seth on more or less exactly that but
only in a pretty restricted domain of
possibilities so i think the general
questions just are still very very open
justin wilcock says do you think there's
any benefit for the average person to
spend more than say 30 minutes a week on
current events news like cnn fox news
msnbc etc the news this week is
particularly sad in america i feel like
i can't change anything other than by
voting which i would have done even if i
didn't watch three hours of cnn and new
york times every day so why not save
some time and do something else
i think this is actually a very
important interesting question it's a
subtle one it's a difficult one because
it's easy to say that all the citizens
who do their voting should be well
informed etc but you have to be a little
bit more specific about to what end
you're being informed one little
footnote to the question is there are
things you can do other than voting you
can convince other people to vote right
you can persuade other people you can
lobby your existing representatives and
those things also have an effect so it's
not just you particularly voting and
when those things happen when you're
talking to other people around you or
when you're lobbying your
representatives maybe it does matter
that you're hyper-informed about a
particular issue you know you come off
as more credible and knowledgeable
however i get the focus of the question
because
we're in a very polarized society right
now you know go back to the podcast we
did with will wilkinson and ezra klein
analyzing just the fact that
the you know polarization
doesn't mean that people are different
from each other it means that their
differences align so that in the
political situation in the united states
right now people who agree or disagree
about a certain issue are more likely
than ever before to agree and disagree
about other issues and that makes it
harder to find overlap but easier to
realize well this candidate is closer to
me than this other candidate right and
so i think that we're in a situation
right now where if you don't need to be
hyper educated about current events to
figure out that one candidate is closer
to your interest than another one is
for better for worse right um so
i i do think that there is a sort of
pragmatic kind of at least in this
current moment argument to say you need
to be
up enough on current events that you can
pick you know are you republican or
democrat roughly speaking and that's
just not that hard and once that happens
uh you know who to vote for and and the
extra information is
maybe interesting and so forth but
doesn't actually affect who you vote for
so again i would i would put the reasons
to become better informed
not
these days as feeding into who you vote
for because that's kind of just too
obvious in our present system unless
you're really right in between which is
a rare but existent species
but there's also other things there's
talking about the issues there's
thinking them through talking with your
representatives writing letters writing
emails joining campaigns you know
deciding when something is significant
enough that you would march or donate
money to an interest group or whatever
so it's for those reasons not for voting
reasons that i do think it is worthwhile
becoming informed about what's going on
casey mahone says have you ever been
through a bad breakup and how did you
get over it
yeah i have i like to think that almost
everyone has right once you reach a
certain age you know some people are
lucky they marry their high school
sweetheart and it works out for their
lives most people in the modern world
aren't like that there are breakups and
sometimes the breakups are bad yeah that
happens and bad doesn't mean you know
you're throwing plates at each other or
whatever it might just mean that it's
sad that you're breaking up for whatever
reason i mean maybe it's sad for one
person and not sad for the other person
i don't have any great advice i don't
think there's any magic bullet here
through getting over those things um the
only time kind of marginally relevant
factoid i will pass along is i once
heard a talk by philip zimbardo who is a
psychologist who's kind of infamous for
the stanford prison experiment
but later in life he's been uh thinking
about the psychology of people's
attitude towards time and you know he
talked actually about the marshmallow
experiment the marshmallow test which
was not his he was not the one who was
walter walter mitchell who did that
first but zimbardo was trying to argue
that
one of the things that is revealed by
the marshmallow test where you're giving
either one you're even two marshmallows
sorry what is it you're given one
marshmallow you're a kid you're like
eight years old or whatever and you're
told either you eat the marshmallow now
when i leave the room or if you don't
eat it i will give you two marshmallows
and the point is supposed to be that
this reveals an orientation of the
person toward time
there are future oriented people present
oriented people and past oriented people
okay and of course this is a wild
exaggeration but there is supposed to be
some effect there supposed to be some
continuum on which people lie and
zimbardo's claim is that
you can test for this are people more
future oriented past oriented present
oriented and it's a more robust
psychological characterization than
almost any other one you can find it's a
very basic fundamental feature of who
people are and to that extent uh i am a
future oriented person
this helps me out getting over the bad
breakups to get back to casey's question
i really do care about what comes next
you know the bad breakups for me are the
ones where i can't get over thinking
that maybe we'll get back together right
if it just is over then i have
relatively little trouble moving on to
the next thing
and it's not that being future oriented
is better intrinsically or more ethical
or moral or self-actualized or whatever
than being past or present-oriented it's
just that
it gives you a slightly different
perspective that i think helps you get
over dwelling on the bad things that
have happened uh you're always getting
excited or or depressed depending on the
situation about what is going to happen
next so maybe the teensy bit of advice
would be to sort of cultivate a
future-oriented perspective in those
situations think about what's going to
happen
what your next thing will be how to make
that come about what are the things you
can do to affect the future that's
something i've always been very
fortunate
that i have uh had as an attitude which
is i don't want to just say things are
bad i want to ask how can i make them
better if if we're just sitting around
talking about how terrible things are
i'm completely uninterested what are the
things we can do to change it that's
what i want to know and that's i sort of
drifted off into more global issues but
i think that works for romantic
entanglements as well
noble gas says your conversation with
nick lane and others offers hope that we
will soon have a plausible understanding
of the origins of life on earth your
conversation with the neil seth and
others offers hope that we will at some
point understand the origins and
emergence of phenomenal phenomenal
consciousness
i see no hope for potentially
understanding the origin of the universe
you've suggested that maybe we just have
to accept a list of brute facts for that
question given the progress we've made
on other hard questions doesn't that
seem like a cop-out do you truly not
think we will be able to do better than
a list of brute facts to truly
understand the origin of our universe
well no i'm someone who definitely
believes we are making progress on
understanding the origin of the universe
that's absolutely something to do and
simultaneously there will be of in
involved in that at some point a list of
brute facts just like for our
understanding of life or consciousness
you know you try to explain the origin
of life but you take as brute facts all
of chemistry right you don't need to say
well until i understand the periodic
table the elements i don't understand
the origin of life there are some facts
you just take as given and you might say
well that's left for physics or
chemistry to explain right that's going
to bottom out somewhere
there is more than one possible world
there's more than one way the world
could have been and at some sense there
might be something special about our
world but even if there is something
special about our world it doesn't
explain why the world is that way it's
just a fact about our world and you know
we in
our everyday lives we often don't want
to just accept brute facts we think that
there's always a deeper explanation but
you can't extend that kind of reasoning
about our everyday lives to big
fundamental questions about the universe
i i am someone who literally believes it
is impossible to imagine
that there aren't brute facts about the
universes precisely because there are
other ways things could have been and
there's just a fact that things are this
way rather than another way
the that doesn't mean we have to just
stop thinking about it because we're not
sure what those brute facts are we can
always try to hope for a better
explanation than what we currently have
that's what we do as scientists and
philosophers
patricia paulsen says i get the
impression you aren't thrilled about
loop quantum gravity i'm just a math
deficient lay person but it just seems
to make sense a smallest distance
doesn't seem any different than discrete
jumps in an electron's orbit or energy
or strings only vibrating in specified
waves with nothing in between wouldn't
that be a type of symmetry so while it
is just my math stupid self saying it
makes sense what are your objections or
what are the objections others have is
it all in the math
well i think that these are perfectly
good
reasons motivations to think about loop
quantum gravity you know this is how
science works how physics works you have
an idea
you develop that idea into a rigorous
theory and then you compare that to how
the world works in in direct or indirect
ways so yeah you can say well maybe
there's sort of a discreteness in
space-time it's a very very natural
thing to say but that's not the end of
your project that's the beginning you
say okay what does that mean
mathematically what predictions does it
make and so forth
does the theory make internal sense is
it coherent is it consistent and things
like that and i think that you know for
all those questions loop quantum gravity
has just not worked there you go like
i'm not against the idea of trying it it
was a great thing to try
but uh it's clearly missing some
important aspects of how gravity works
in the real world the most obvious one
are the non-local aspects of gravity the
aspects that show up in holography and
complementarity and black hole
information these are all things that
were understood first outside the
context of loop quantum gravity um i
mean there's no puzzle or
feature that seems to be universal about
gravity as far as i know that was first
brought up or discovered in the context
of lukewarm from gravity they've
discovered things that are
supposedly true in the context of their
theory which is great but i think that
the arguments for things like holography
are robust enough that they should be
true at any theory of quantum gravity
and this idea that you just put degrees
of freedom at local positions in space
is exactly not holographic that's
exactly not you know set up to be
compatible with that fact about the
gravitational universe so
yeah maybe they just haven't gotten
there yet it's always possible but
that's just true again for all of
physics when there's lots of different
theories
on the floor and you need to pick which
one you're looking at you know all of
them are possible maybe they could be
developed with smarter people doing
really good work into something that
fits the data but you have to choose
what seems more promising than others
and it seems to me that the basic first
moves of loop quantum gravity are not
the moves to make as far as we
understand in other things that we've
learned about about quantum gravity more
generally
michael lesniak says i'm really
interested to hear your take on the
movie tenet and how it portrays entropy
as a means to time travel does it hold
together and does having to breathe
backward air even make any sense so the
short answer is no it makes no sense at
all it's completely movie fiction it's
fantasy it's not science fiction it's
sort of inspired by uh you know various
scientific ideas about entropy and the
arrow of time and things like that but
there's no real science to what happens
in tenant is the short answer and that's
okay you know i haven't seen the movie
in a while so i can't tell you details
but i can enjoy the movie as a movie
it's as realistic as you know the fast
and furious franchise in many ways
there's a lot of things that are not
very realistic there but still enjoy the
movie that's okay
moshe fader says i recently completed a
house hunt that took roughly a year so
i'm curious about what sort of house you
and jennifer are shopping for in the
baltimore area do you have a target size
in mind do you prefer modern or
traditional architecture
yeah well these are all very relevant
questions uh to my brain right now i'm
thinking about them every single day uh
we still have not found a house that
we've settled down on but with the
internet these days it's kind of amazing
you know we can do a lot of house
hunting from california even if we're
hunting for houses in baltimore they put
a lot of information online which is
very very helpful but there's nothing
quite like stepping into the house and
you know feeling it and smelling it and
looking at the sight lines and imagining
where your sofa will be and all those
questions so the nice thing about
baltimore is that real estate is way
more affordable than it is in los
angeles you know los angeles is
cheaper than
a couple of other cities the united
states maybe new york san francisco
boston but still pretty expensive by any
uh ordinary stretch of the imagination
so when we sell our house here we will
be able to buy a house that is much
larger in baltimore now there's two sort
of
basic modes you can get kind of a
townhouse downtown maybe close to the
waterfront or something like that those
are very very nice very beautiful
there's a big selection and there are
also you know big older houses a lot of
hundred-year-old houses there's there
was sort of a building boom in baltimore
a hundred years ago especially near the
campus near hopkins and so
i think we're leaning in the latter
direction i mean i think that if we had
infinite money and could pick houses
anywhere in the world and build our own
from scratch we would go very modern in
terms of architecture very contemporary
uh but given what exists uh i think
there are beautiful
colonials that are you know a 15-minute
walk from campus that are surrounded by
leafy nice neighborhoods that you know
would be great with lots of square feet
so probably something like that um
jennifer is very uh energized to you
know renovate a kitchen tear out some
floors replace them with better flooring
things like that so i can't that just uh
sounds exhausting to me but i think that
uh we'll we'll work out something it you
know it's it's both exciting and
nerve-wracking at the same time right
it's a big thing we expect to live there
for a long number of years
and uh so you want to choose right from
the start we'll probably move there into
an apartment for a little while uh since
we haven't found the perfect place yet
and then uh keep hunting for houses in
the months to come
rue phillips says i've heard you allude
to the fact that you are now working on
quantum gravity research did i hear you
correctly what are you hoping to
accomplish in that field in the near
term uh the next two years
so
yeah i am i am doing quantum gravity
i've even done a there's a whole solo
podcast on it from early days uh that
about the emergence of space-time from
quantum mechanics which is a kind of
quantum gravity and you know by the way
you don't need to wonder about these
things you can just look for any
scientist what they're working on by
looking at what papers they've written
you can go to google scholar for example
there's various other more specialized
lists of uh publications that you can
find online but google scholar has a
pretty good coverage overall
uh in all fields it's a little bit
difficult because you know there are
other people named sean carroll like
previous mindscape guests who are
biologists and so forth but if you put
in the middle initial um you can find my
publications very easily and just you
know search by date you know sort by
date and then you'll find out what i've
been working on lately um
what i do i hope to accomplish the next
two years is almost impossible to answer
because in theoretical physics you
do what can be what yeah you do what can
be done right uh so there are many
things i would like to do but within
this idea that we have of starting with
a finite dimensional quantum system and
seeing how space time can emerge there's
a number of obvious questions to ask
about the emergence of lorenzen variants
the emergence of quantum fields
whether or not the metric that you can
define using entanglement is physically
the metric that is felt by propagating
particles and fields in that geometry
things like that so there's a whole
bunch of things you know the particular
angle i have is very
new and immature compared to something
like loop quantum gravity or string
theory or causal set theory or whatever
so many of the very basic questions
haven't been answered which always means
that as i as i always want to emphasize
the whole thing could crash and burn
very quickly it could just not work you
don't know uh but we're trying i think
that it's optimistic that we're going to
make some progress progress has
certainly definitely been slowed by the
fact that i'm moving from caltech to
hopkins and therefore at the moment i
have no students or postdocs working
with me so um you know my publication
rate is going to be smaller this year
and next year but i'm hoping to ramp
that back up once i get to baltimore
john sorry rob patro says you recently
had a nice thread on twitter about
determinism and free will it spurred a
nice follow-up thread on what it means
for a system to be deterministic my
question is is our best model of the
universe deterministic despite quantum
mechanics perhaps i don't know which of
the many worlds holds my future but it
would seem the entire tree or directed
acyclic graph of the universe is
entirely determined including the
probability amplitudes of each branch
so there's two senses here one is that
in many worlds the wave function of the
universe
evolves deterministically as we've
already said that is true but that's
irrelevant to observers you don't care
about that because you only live on one
branch at a time okay so to you there's
a probability distribution and
that doesn't count as being
deterministic so if all you can predict
about the future are the probabilities
of certain events that that's great
that's a huge accomplishment
scientifically but it does not count as
saying that the world is deterministic
just because the probability
distribution evolves deterministically
doesn't mean the world does so uh even
so once you take quantum mechanics into
account i think that the right thing to
say is that our world the world that we
observe is just not deterministic for
all intents and purposes
paul hess says in your interview with
sean b carroll just mentioned the idea
was raised that the mutation rate of
organisms is in theory adjustable if you
could adjust the human mutation rate
would you increase it greatly in
response to the much more rapid changes
in climate and technology we are facing
or reduce it greatly to provide a stable
base for adaptation using technology our
race is going through non-biological
evolution
um
well i particularly my individual self
would not mess with the human mutation
rate and that's because you know it's
it's
more or less not not precisely because
there are things that we can't control
but biology has
tuned that mutation rate to be just
about right if the mutation rate is
larger remember most mutations are bad
okay
most mutations kill you
or at least harm you in some way because
we're pretty close to optimized given
the general features that we have as
biological organisms not just human
beings but all mature species are like
that if you slow it down the mutation
rate then it is harder to make
even more progress biologically so it's
probably about right now you are
pointing out correctly that we are
living in a time when our conditions are
changing more rapidly than usual so this
mutation rate that has been selected or
controlled by natural selection um is
meant for a time when changes are
slower that's true
but
like you also say there are ways that we
can adapt to our changing circumstances
that are not through changing our
genomes through non-biological or
technological changes so i think that i
would be cautious in this particular way
you know there's also the question of
individual
not rights but individual welfare versus
group welfare right if you increase the
mutation rate in human beings by any
noticeable amount you would get a lot
more sick babies and those individuals
would suffer even if
occasionally some of them would adapt in
a positive way and so the question is
you know how many people do you want to
suffer just to make some that are doing
better and i'm not in favor of really
increasing that number by a great amount
igor parshkin says my question is about
the equality sign in mathematics i
always imagined to myself it means that
two sides of the equation are completely
equivalent i.e f equals ma is saying
that the force is
acceleration just with a proportionality
constant they're the same thing just in
different words but i recently recently
realized that this does not always hold
for example the schrodinger equation
says h psi equals e psi it doesn't mean
that using an operator is the same thing
as energy so in short what does equality
mean in math
so i think there's a few things going on
that i need to clear up here one is that
the schrodinger equation does not say h
psi equals e psi
that is the time independent schrodinger
equation which is just a special case of
the real schrodinger equation the real
schrodinger equation says h psi
equals i d by dt psi the time derivative
of psi okay so that's a much more
general thing from which you can derive
the equation that you wrote down
the other thing is that you're asking
about what equality means in math but
your examples are all what equality
means in physics which are different
things you know equality doesn't mean
identity it doesn't mean um that two
things are defined to be the same thing
so you give f equals m a as a as an
example but um think about the inverse
square law for gravity right the force
of gravity is
g newton's constant times the mass of
one the mass of the other divided by r
squared
uh that's not supposed to be telling you
that the force
is that one over r squared uh thing
times the masses it's numerically equal
to it but it's conceptually a different
thing that's what's going on in the
schrodinger equation and it's even much
more obvious in einstein's equation for
general relativity in general relativity
you have r mu nu minus one half r g mu
nu on the left hand side and even if you
don't know what those symbols mean what
they're telling you is the curvature of
space-time okay and on the right-hand
side you have eight pi g t mu nu which
is telling you the energy and momentum
in space-time conceptually two
completely different things the equation
is just telling you they are numerically
equal in solutions to einstein's
equations in other words in classical
space times in the real world so that's
always the way you should think about it
in physics and the physics an equation
is telling you that two differently
defined quantities are numerically equal
to each other
in math it can mean lots of different
things because math is not about a
substance right math is not about
uh an individual domain of applicability
math is more general than that math is
about syntax more than semantics if you
want to put it that way it's about the
symbols more than their meaning the the
same symbols can mean different things
but two plus two equals four whether the
two things and the four things are
apples or oranges or whatever okay so
it's a slightly different meaning in
math and in physics but in either case
is equality supposed to mean uh these
two things are the same concepts it just
means they're numerically equal
alejandro del rincon says according to
general relativity mass and energy warp
space-time
i'm not sure this is a sensible question
but why
is there an interaction between the two
or some sort of friction that causes the
warping
well you know this is dangerously close
to the kind of question that the answer
is it just is that way right i mean
that's the equation that's what the
theory says the theory postulates that
mass and energy warp space-time but as i
said above you know sometimes you can
kind of try to derive equations like
that through some other principles but
you're just replacing one set of
postulates for another so you're you're
welcome to just postulate einstein's
equation of general relativity and and
say this is the
one of the postulates of the theory um
nothing wrong with that in that case it
just is true but you can also derive it
from some other set of postulates for
example the principle of least action
the principle of least action says that
along physical trajectories if you
imagine the space of all possible
trajectories for a system which in
general relativity means the space of
all possible space times between some
initial configuration and some final
configuration
and then you can calculate a number
called the action for all of those
trajectories or all of those space times
and what you find is that the one that
is actually a solution to the equation
the motion is the one that has the
minimum value of the action and this
makes perfect sense when it's a simple
system like a ball rolling down a hill
where the action is an integral over
time of the kinetic energy minus the
potential energy so it's not the uh the
total energy which is just constant
along the trajectory but it's basically
some kind of competition between kinetic
energy and potential energy so you're
trying to minimize kinetic energy minus
potential energy along a path between
two points and you might say well good
so just minimize the potential energy is
always positive and the kinetic energy
is always positive by themselves let's
say that you've set things up that way
and you want to minimize kinetic minus
potential
that means go to very large values of
the potential and very small values of
the kinetic energy right the problem is
you have a boundary condition you just
start somewhere and end somewhere and
you set up your initial condition so you
start at some place at some time and you
end at some other place at some other
time and subject to those constraints
you want to minimize the kinetic energy
minus the potential energy which sort of
means roughly speaking you go as slow as
you can to get to where you want to go
in the right amount of time you don't
just speed really fast and get there and
sit there that's not the solution to the
equations of motion so in general
relativity
translating those words into the context
of curved space-time says that there's a
balance there's a trade-off just like
versus kinetic and potential energy
there's a balance or a trade-off between
the amount of stuff in the universe and
the curvature of space-time so
space-time curves as little as it can to
adapt to the amount of energy that it
has in it to minimize the action there
uh
in some sense that's no better than just
postulating the final answer because
well why is that action the one that is
minimized by these trajectories right
but you know this is how the world works
uh the world is full of fields like the
gravitational field they all
move and vibrate and oscillate and they
all interact with each other in one way
or another the stuff in the universe
that makes up matter interacts with the
stuff that makes up space time and
that's gives us the equation that we
have at the end of the day
abdi eow says with all the craziness and
madness going on in the world right now
do you think one day in the future
hopefully soon the james webb space
telescope will find something that blows
people's minds and brings humanity
closer for the purpose of advancing
humanity's civilization
so there's two left there's a good
question two levels of answer here
one is is the web space telescope going
to find amazing things and the other is
will that bring humanity closer together
you know in the latter question honestly
i don't think so by any
reasonable amount you know the kinds of
things that historically have ended wars
or uh in induced world peace are not
scientific discoveries as far as i can
tell they are there they do play some
role you know science is um
part of the legacy of all of humanity
doesn't belong to any one person or
country or anything like that and
everyone can be impressed and wonder at
a great scientific discovery but
empirically the the effect of that on on
human behavior is is pretty small
the other is you know will the webb
space telescope make these
world-shattering discoveries you know i
don't know um it will certainly make big
discoveries because they're sort of
targets you know the thing about
building a new telescope or a new
scientific experiment is you can't
predict what you're going to see
otherwise if you knew what you're going
to see you wouldn't build it you would
save the money
so you're looking into the unknown a
little bit and that's part of the
excitement however you can't get money
from nasa or congress without
giving good expectations that you're
going to see something interesting so
for the web uh there's two obvious
targets here one is galaxies in the
early universe the early
the very early formation of stars and
galaxies right because the the web is is
focused on infrared radiation
so unlike the hubble space telescope
which is looking at visible light jwst
is looking at longer wavelengths and one
of the reasons why that's interesting is
because if you have a galaxy that is
very early that is just like our galaxy
mostly
giving off radiation in the visible
spectrum
once it gets to us it's redshifted to
the infrared so you're you have
optimized yourself to look further back
in time if you build an infrared
telescope like jwst so that's
interesting
um but it will like it mostly be
interesting to astronomers and
cosmologists right
we know that galaxies exist
understanding how they are assembled and
understanding how stars light up is very
very interesting but it won't be a
complete world shattering shock
the other thing the jwst that i know
about that it's going to look for are
exoplanets and features of exoplanets
planets around other star systems so
that is is very exciting we know less in
some sense about exoplanets than we know
about other galaxies we found thousands
of exoplanets and trillions of galaxies
so or you know millions of galaxies
anyway that we've actually found
so that has
for obvious reasons that i don't need to
delineate here the prospect of being
really really exciting if everything
goes well probably we'll just get an
inventory of exoplanets right
but we could get more interesting things
as well you know that's something to
hold out hope for
matt lane says do we need more academics
to get involved in and run for political
office what could we do to support a
higher level of education and discourse
in our politics
well i think that
there are some academics who'll be great
running for political office and some
have successfully
many academics would be terrible at
politics i don't think there's any
intrinsic connection between being an
academic and being good at politics you
know in the modern world for better or
for worse
the job of being a politician a lot of
it is either fundraising or negotiating
with your fellow politicians right those
are the things it's not about just
having the right policy prescriptions
it's about getting things done with
those policy prescriptions so and i
think that a lot of people you know fall
in love with this or that politician
because they say the right things but
personally i want to know what they've
gotten done what legislation has they
gotten past or what reforms have they
accomplished or or whatever that's
another level of trickiness and again
one that academics are not themselves
especially good at um but the you know
this is related to the second half of
your question is should we have a higher
level of education and discourse
that's an easier one yes i think that we
should
you know in many ways our current
political system here in the united
states and i think also elsewhere it's a
little weird you know someone was
pointing out the ages of the people who
wrote the
constitution of the united states um a
lot of them a lot of the people you know
the both the continental congress that
did the declaration of independence and
then also at the um uh when they wrote
the constitution they were in their 20s
and 30s a lot of them and a few were in
their 40s almost none were in their 60s
and 70s ben franklin was an old founding
father back in the day but you know
jefferson and hamilton all those people
madison you know they were young and
they were super educated right you know
they spoke latin you know they had all
these libraries full of books from of
greek philosophy uh that congress had
access to and they were really up on the
latest writings from uh europe about
thinking about the social contract and
the enlightenment and human rights and
things like that in a way that let's
just say our current political
leadership is not on either side of the
aisle um
so we've gotten away from that highly
educated you know in the united states
for all of its flaws of the current
system for all the flaws the
constitution has we were really lucky in
many ways to get people who wrote it who
were very smart and also very
high-minded you know they had their
interests in mind but they really were
earnestly trying to put together a
system that they thought would work we
all know that there are there were
failures of that system the most obvious
one is the fact that it didn't include
slaves or women or et cetera et cetera
and you could argue whether or not it
possibly could have but but it doesn't
matter the point is for the
present argument
if we tried to sit down and write a
constitution now just by voting people
into some sort of congressional assembly
or constitutional convention and had
them write it i would be horrified at
what might come out i would have very
very low expectations at what might
appear from that uh i don't know
mandatory gun ownership or something
like that i don't know what it would be
but um
it would be nice if uh the discourse
that we had in our current political
system was a little bit more elevated i
don't know how to get there i'd have no
practical suggestions along those lines
sorry about that
alex b says if jurassic park were real
and an escaped t-rex was hunting down
humans trapped in the park would you
support killing it to save humans even
if it was the last of its kind well yes
that'll be pretty easy both for sort of
moral ethical reasons i think that the
inner life of a human being is much
richer and more valuable than that of a
tyrannosaurus but also
if jurassic park were real by
construction we just made a t-rex so
it's not the last of its kind we can
just make another one i know that's sort
of cheating around your thought
experiment there but in general you know
i take human life to be more valuable
than the lives of other animals
that's not absolute there are spectra
here you know there's a continuum we're
not completely different completely
distinct from other kinds of uh living
beings here on earth we're all part of
the same family et cetera et cetera but
having said that you know i do think
that i i think that human beings are
just different in the real world for
practical purposes
jesse rimler says in the may ama you
answered a question regarding the
russian invasion of ukraine
in your answer you stated that noam
chomsky had recently called for ukraine
to lie down and take it and surrender to
russia i've read chomsky's statement and
i don't think your comment reflects his
statements to be fair you said it was a
rough paraphrase here is my summary of
chomsky's position the u.s should use
its influence to encourage a settlement
between ukraine and russia in order to
end the war he notes that this
diplomatic solution would not be just
but that the results of international
diplomacy rarely are he says that
ukraine's resistance under zelinski has
been honorable and that russian
aggression is criminal not unlike our
invasion of iraq he critiques the us's
current stance which is to support the
war down to the last ukrainian which
will almost certainly lead to protracted
conflict that kills more ukrainians and
terrifyingly raises the chances for
nuclear war do you believe this position
to be unreasonable well i don't know
whether it's reasonable or not but i
believe it to be wrong and the reason is
it's not a matter of supporting the war
down to the last ukrainian it's a matter
of supporting what the ukrainians want
i'm in favor of thinking less about what
are what is in the united states
interests in this particular question
and thinking about what is in the
interests of the people in ukraine and
they want to resist so i'm in favor of
it i'm in favor of helping them resist
if that's what they want i think the
invasion was completely illegal and
immoral and wrong
and it should not be allowed to stand if
there's any way of resisting it and the
ukrainians so far have been really
really good at resisting it i think that
we should count our lucky stars that
they have been that good and give them
all the help that we can
nicholas worsley says if and when
quantum gravity is figured out do you
think relativity will be taught as a
step like newtonian physics or is it
likely we don't need it at all
well
relativity is clearly going to be taught
like newtonian physics and yeah this is
a this is a feature of how science works
it's not just one theory that is right
and all the other theories that are
wrong there are theories that are right
as limiting cases of other theories so
when quantum gravity is figured out it
will almost certainly be the case in
fact i'm tempted to say certainly if i
if i were indulging in such rhetoric
that there will be a limit a classical
limit of quantum gravity that looks like
general relativity right how do we know
that well because general relativity is
super duper successful at accounting for
things like gravitational lensing the
orbit of mercury the prediction of black
holes gravitational waves the expansion
of the universe at early times and so on
and so on so
it is absolutely completely respectable
to use classical general relativity
rather than quantum gravity even if
quantum gravity is figured out in the
regime where classical general
relativity applies and the thing is that
the regime where there is gravity
noticeable at all
is almost entirely in the regime where
classical general relativity applies so
it's really kind of the other way around
if we figure out quantum gravity that'll
be great that'll be great for physics
it'll be a huge monumental intellectual
achievement but as a practical matter if
you need to do a calculation in
astrophysics or cosmology you're just
going to use classical general
relativity just like if we want to fly a
rocket to the moon we use newtonian
physics perfectly well
mark shorn says the last three volume
feynman lectures on physics sorry the
three volume prime lectures on physics
represented quite a radical departure
from the usual freshman physics textbook
it seems to have been largely a failure
since as far as i know no introductory
physics textbook since much resembles it
even if it's much beloved by more
advanced students i'm curious what your
thoughts are on the books and whether
there might be a better way to present
introductory physics rather than the
traditional way
so
i think that the feynman lectures are
not a failure but they're not a
model for other
physics textbooks i don't think that's a
very useful thing
useful way to think about them they are
used by plenty of people by students
trying to learn physics by teachers who
teach freshman physics to get ideas for
clever ways to teach things but they're
at a slightly higher level than you want
for traditional physics um curriculum
and also there's there's no problem sets
in the books themselves there's other
books that have come out since that have
that have problems and you know feynman
does like to to ramble on sometimes and
he also has his own individual things
that he's interested in right that are
fascinating they're all really cool but
they kind of slow you down if you're
just trying to get to the basics of
physics you're trying to teach the first
year students so i think that they're
extremely successful as what they are
which are
textbooks and physics that are good to
dip into in many areas that's true there
are many books in you know general
relativity or quantum field theory or
whatever that are wonderful reference
books and books to have on your shelf
once you've learned the subject but not
the best books to learn it from the
start
uh in terms of is there a better way to
present introductory physics
i honestly don't know i've never taught
introductory physics i've not taken it
for many many years
i have no strong thoughts on it i would
be happy if there were
more glimpses of the future in
introductory physics courses so not just
here as an inclined plane but a little
bit of an introduction to the frontiers
of physics to get people a little bit
more excited but that's just sort of a
bonus extra thing to put in there it's
not really a restructuring of the of the
basic curriculum itself
kathy seeger says in the last chapters
of something deeply hidden you write
about an emerging metric of space from
the entanglement structure of the
quantum state from there you go on to
defining areas a collection of degrees
of freedom to be proportional to their
entanglement entropy and that leads to a
geometry of space
could this approach be run on a computer
simulation
model or is it more likely a highly
theoretical lapassian demon thing for
which you have to know all the specifics
beforehand to get something out of it
i think it's somewhere in between um you
know there's no obstacle in principle to
running this kind of idea on a computer
but it would be very small scale you
know the the thing about that we think
is true about space-time if it does
emerge from quantum mechanics is there's
a huge number of degrees of freedom in
every very very tiny region of space i
forget what the number is i think i once
figured out that in a cubic centimeter
of space we're postulating something
like uh hilbert space of dimension 10 to
the 10 to the 60th right so that's a lot
of numbers a lot of degrees of freedom
that you're not going to be able to put
on a computer anytime soon so what you
really be doing is a very very highly
constrained toy model with just a few
degrees of freedom because
simulating quantum things on classical
computers is famously hard and that's
one of the reasons why quantum computers
were invented in the first place
but in principle you know the equations
should work out
such that the structure is similar to
the rest of physics where you have
initial conditions and you can evolve
them over time or you just try to solve
the quantum equations through the path
integral or whatever it is but it's it's
the same kind of approach as in the rest
of physics
jordan dansby says can you speak to the
quantum mechanics of climate change
specifically the quantum concepts at
play if any in the manner in which co2
molecules trap heat energy radiating
from the earth's surface
so the short answer is no
i mean there are obviously quantum
mechanics uh ideas that are required to
understand why
certain
compounds in our atmosphere let certain
wavelengths of light through and trap
other wavelengths of light i mean the
basic idea of the greenhouse effect is
that we get visible light from the sun
we put things in the atmosphere that are
transparent to visible light but opaque
to infrared light and it's the infrared
light that is actually emitted back from
the earth so you let light in but you
don't let light out and we heat up
that's the greenhouse effect now
you can derive
in principle what frequencies of light
will pass through different kinds of
gases from the principles of quantum
mechanics i myself can't do that i mean
i could do that if you sat me down with
a textbook and gave me time i could do
it but i haven't thought about those
calculations
mostly forever or even if i have it's
been a very long time so i can't do it
off the top of my head but also more
importantly the reason i want to answer
the question is it doesn't matter it
really doesn't once you know the answer
once you know the spectrum of light that
passes through these particular kinds of
gases which you can get just empirically
just experimentally just put the gas in
a jar and pass light through it and see
what spectrum goes through and what
which one is absorbed that's all you
need you don't need any quantum
mechanics for that and that's all the
science uh that you really need at the
same time it's the simplest level of
science you need to talk about climate
change and the greenhouse effect etc so
this is again you know i don't want to
harp on the same things over and over
again this is emergence at work you
don't need to know the microphysics to
understand what's happening at the macro
level once you understand the
interaction of light and the gases
that's what you need for the higher
level computation such as climate change
bruno teshera says isn't strong
emergence kind of anti-naturalist what
am i missing uh i don't think it's
necessarily anti-naturalist so strong
emergence is the idea well
let me back up a little bit
i'm not sure that people give very good
definitions of strong emergence and as
i've said many times the sad thing about
discussions of immersions is they all
devolve into discussions of the
definition of emergence which is
incredibly boring and so i don't i don't
kind of want to worry too much about the
definition so let me tell you my
idea that comes to mind when someone
says strong emergence we imagine that
there is a way of thinking about some
thing in the universe by dividing it up
into constituents right so you can think
about the table in front of me as made
of atoms or you can think about society
is made of people okay in either case
you're taking a big system and dividing
up into a set of interacting smaller
systems
and then weak emergence is supposed to
be the idea that we have a theory of the
individual constituents the atoms or the
people or whatever and we put that all
on a computer that theory and in
principle we had a sufficiently powerful
computer and the theory of the
individual constituents we could put
them all together in an initial
condition run it and we would get the
right answer
but
we could also just discuss the
collective at the same time so i can
discuss the tensile strength and the
color and things like that of the table
in front of me without knowing anything
about the atoms and at the same time if
i did know about the atoms i could put
them on a computer and
derive the properties of the table
that's weak emergence
strong emergence is you have a theory of
the fundamental constituents but if you
put it together put just a bunch of
constituents individually on a computer
and asked what happened you would not
get the right answer
for whatever reason okay
so that could be an anti-naturalist
position because it could be that
you're saying you don't get the right
answer because something spooky and
ineffable comes in and changes the
behavior of the system that's one
possibility but another possibility is
that what you thought was a completely
comprehensive theory of the constituents
actually wasn't
maybe the correct theory of the
constituents is different if the
constituents are just talking to each
other one to one versus being embedded
in some larger collection okay that
would be a in in principle completely
naturalist kind of strong emergence and
again i'm not completely sure that makes
sense but i can at least imagine it i
don't i don't know that it doesn't make
sense um it doesn't happen
in
if your tiny systems are atoms or
molecules or elementary particles
because those obey local laws of physics
as we talked about earlier in the ama
they don't care whether they're in an
atom or a rock or a table or
interstellar space all the electron
cares about is what the fields of
other fields are doing at the same point
in space time so there's no room for
strong emergence there but if your small
systems are something like people
then maybe this the relationship is more
complicated you know we have a very
clean crisp relationship between atoms
and gases or solids the relationship
between people and societies is a little
bit messier where you draw the
boundaries and how do things affect each
other and stuff like that so
i'm open to the possibility
that when the individual constituents
are themselves complex
there might be situations in which
strong emergence is a useful way of
thinking about things i don't know for
sure that there is but i'm open to that
possibility
gregory kuznick says since we can't know
the details of our present microstate
we're forced to accept that there's a
set of possible past microstates from
which our current state could have
evolved it seems to me that observations
of events in the present constrain the
set of past microstates in much the same
way they constrain future microstates
but the conventional view of causality
says that it only flows into one
direction from past future what then
should we call the backward flowing kind
of constraint
well as i've discussed before
you're right that from
only
our observations of our present macro
state you would be able to say the same
kinds of things
about the future and about the past the
present microstate implies more or less
similar sets of possibilities for once
one direction of time and the other but
that's not the universe we live in or at
least that's not all we have access to
we also have the past hypothesis we also
know that the early universe had low
entropy so that's an extra feature we
have about the past that we don't have
about the future there is no known or
plausibly conjectured future boundary
condition that ties things down at all
so it's not that there's something
intrinsic to time that lets us take the
current microstate and talk about its
past and future development differently
it's that we have an extra piece of
information in the past and it's from
that extra piece of information the low
entropy past that we derive the fact
that at the emergent higher level there
are things called cause and effect
relationships that flow from the past to
the future so i think what you're
thinking of is just the past hypothesis
ross hastings asked a priority question
i've been sufficiently troubled by your
conversation with sally hasslinger that
i've waited some months before
commenting and in the light of global
events since it sits all the more
uncomfortably today i'm a lifelong
leftist who believes that woke ideology
is dangerous divisive elitist and
actually racist and i would love to hear
some balancing commentary on your show
my question today is will you consider
talking with an alternative voice
the short answer is no i will not
consider talking with an alternative
voice about those specific issues about
anti-wokism or anything like that for a
number of reasons i mean first and
primarily a sufficient reason is
that's not what this podcast is about
mindscape is about trying to understand
the world trying to understand uh
hopefully eternal truths eternal might
be an exaggeration because
political economic social literary
truths still count and those are a
little bit more ephemeral
but it's about
analysis and about understanding
difficult issues it is not about
fighting whatever culture war battle is
occupying people's attention at the
moment i'm happy to have people on the
show who are active in such battles on
either side but i'm not going to talk to
them about that okay i actually you know
i think that such battles are important
i don't want to discount them there are
many important things that we don't do
here on mindscape
here we're trying to do something
different and i like the fact that we're
trying to do something different i will
have sally hasslinger on the podcast but
it wasn't a rant about wokism we were
talking about the social construction of
reality this is a crucially important
philosophical topic i had neil ferguson
on the podcast and he kept wanting to
talk about cancelled culture but i was
more interested in talking about history
and complexity and organizations and
things like that we had joshua monk on
the podcast who has been outspoken on
these issues on the other side also but
we talked about liberal democracy that
was what he's an expert on and we hope
to understand the world a little bit
better so that's what i'm all about here
also however you know i i want to be
completely honest here
in my view the intellectual case such as
it is offered by these anti-woke folks
is incredibly weak and unpersuasive
almost hilariously so
and i i do want to have different
perspectives on the podcast but i don't
have any perspective on the podcast my
rule has always been i want to bring
people on the podcast who have something
interesting to say even if i disagree
with them very deeply like you know
philip gough talking about pancychism i
completely disagree
but i do think it's an important thing
to think about it's a perspective that
shouldn't be dismissed
i'm not going to have astrologers or
flat earthers and to me this is the
category that these anti-woke people are
in in in my view discrimination and
systemic biases are just extremely real
and perfectly obvious a truly horrible
aspect of life in the modern world i
mean it's i can't see how someone can
deny the existence of these things and
be outraged by them and want to fight to
get them fight against them i think that
what we need to do
is the hard work of figuring out where
these systematic
systemic biases are
fighting against them and more
importantly recognizing the biases
within ourselves that cause us to deny
their existence people go bending over
backwards to sort of ignore the
discrimination that is right in front of
them if it makes them feel bad and i
think that's kind of silly and
embarrassing and we need to do better
that's not to say i will not disagree
with the tactics used by people on the
more woke side if you want to call them
that i very often do disagree with the
tactics used the strategies
but my goals are entirely aligned with
people who are against racism sexism
transphobia etc if my goals are the same
as theirs then fundamentally we're
allies and when i disagree with them it
is in the service of better attaining
the goals so i'm much more of a free
speech absolutist than a typical woke
person is i want to allow all sorts of
speakers on campus even people who i
think are truly terrible if some tiny
group of students on campus wants to
invite a terrible speaker then i'm
entirely in favor of that and i don't
even think you should heckle them i
should i think you should let them give
their talk but the reason why i think
that is because i think the principle of
letting anyone give talks and hearing
their voices is fundamentally a
principle that will ultimately help
fight discrimination and racism etc
rather than
using
silencing as a tool i think that's just
a mistake of strategy but the fact that
i disagree on strategy doesn't mean i
disagree on goals and i don't treat
those people as
my enemies or the people i'm fighting
against
so i mean i think if a person with a
public platform
says that they're let's say anti-racist
but then you listen to how they spend
their time on their public platform and
they're never complaining about racism
but they're often complaining about the
excesses of anti-racism
then you know effectively they're
fighting for the other side whatever may
be lurking inside their heart their
actual actions speak differently and so
i'm just not interested in in giving
them an even bigger voice
and that's that the final thing i will
say is there's no shortage of places on
the internet where you can hear that
perspective uh being said right it's not
like some plucking minority which can't
get its message out the anti-woke um
campaign or whatever you want to call it
plenty of places where you can hear that
perspective being articulated if
anything what i want to do if only sort
of by example is to reclaim the language
of logic and truth and facts which has
been appropriated sometimes by these
people and i think it's been wildly
misappropriated i think that they're
denying science they're not being
vigorously logical and careful they're
using a lot of sophistry to prop up a
lot of very questionable points of view
so i want to be a counter example i
don't want to help them out they don't
need my help they're very very noisy
they're very very uh ubiquitous across
these platforms so what i am standing
for here is something very different
than that
brian tidmore says if humankind were to
advance technologically enough to build
a machine that could manipulate gravity
do you have any guesses what such a
device might look like would it need to
be capable of manipulating quantum
fields particles or would it function in
ways scientists cannot presently imagine
well
i can i had there are machines that
manipulate gravity they're called
uh masses
large objects manipulate gravity by
causing gravity i think that there is
you know a possible um
conceptual error in thinking about
manipulating gravity in a way that is
different from simply putting a heavy
object there and let it attract things
because that's really all we can do when
it comes to manipulating gravity the
reason why that we think that maybe we
can do otherwise is because the other
example that we have in nature of a
long-range force is electromagnetism
and so we sort of train ourselves on
electromagnetism and think maybe someday
we'll be able to do similar things with
gravity
but the huge difference is that for
electromagnetism we have positive
charges and negative charges
for gravity roughly speaking we only
have positive charges everything
attracts right there i say roughly
speaking because there's some little
footnotes but for technological purposes
those footnotes are not very relevant
roughly speaking gravitationally
everything attracts everything to
everything else gravity is a very dumb
simple force in that way whereas
electromagnetism from the simple fact
that there are positive charges and
negative charges is sort of infinitely
manipulatable because you can create
sets of many positive charges and
negative charges and have some of them
go in motion and so forth and create all
sorts of very delicately tuned electric
and magnetic fields
with
gravity you just can't do that with a
positive charge and a negative charge
you can cancel out electric fields in
different places and amplify them in
other places with gravity all you can do
is create more of it
or less of it by taking an object and
move it further away so roughly i think
that as far as we currently understand
gravity we're not going to be able to
manipulate it in the same way that we
can manipulate electromagnetic fields
timothy carroll asks a priority question
i'm very aware of your presentation of
the particle at the end of the universe
and the halls of the royal institution
it's been nine years since your
beautiful explanation on the hunt for
the higgs some physicists feel that the
construction of a new particle collider
with higher power is not the best use of
research dollars do you feel the same
way or could you justify this extreme
financial burden for a new facility
you know i think it's an important
question and a difficult question
but it's not a question you should
expect an objective answer to for two
reasons number one is uh
we do not have a fixed pot of money that
we sit down and say what is the best way
we can spend this on research right it's
not like there's a fixed number of
dollars we say okay biology gets so many
and chemistry gets so many and particle
physics gets so many this is a lesson
that has been beaten home over and over
again when we've had an expensive
science project that people have
campaigned against on the theory that
the money could be better spent
elsewhere and the project gets cancelled
and guess what the money does not get
spent on science at all because there's
no rule that the amount of money spent
on science has to be fixed so generally
when you have these giant particle
accelerators or telescopes or whatever
the question is not do you spend it on
this or do you spend it on other science
the question is do you spend it on this
or do you just spend on something
completely different not scientific at
all
and the other thing is you know this is
not a decision made by the world right
these facilities are built in countries
and the countries or the groups of
countries that build them generally
decide what they want to do with the
money uh so if some country if china or
europe or whoever wants to build a giant
particle accelerator that's the choice
that they are going to make or not make
again it doesn't come out of the money
from other countries
and finally i think i said two things
but it's really three things
there is a difference between building a
giant particle accelerator and doing
other kinds of experiments namely that
the kinds of answers you would get the
kind of things you would learn from a
giant particle accelerator are just not
achievable in any other way
you can
do experiments in you know cosmic rays
or tabletop experiments and maybe you
will get a hint of the existence of
other particles but you can't figure out
what particles they are you just can't
get the detailed close-up look and
there's some kinds of new particles that
you just can't discover in that indirect
way you just have to smash other
particles together and see what comes
out that's really the only thing that
you can do
so when you were thinking about whether
or not it's worth the money and again i
have no idea whether it's worth money
because i don't know what the options
are and spending the money otherwise uh
but when you're figuring that out it is
it's just a mistake to compare it to to
say like well i spent a million dollars
on this and got a certain research
output but this is costing 10 billion
dollars is it really 10 000 times
worth 10 000 of the original experiment
because the original experiments don't
scale like that you know if you have
some really really good tabletop atomic
physics experiment that costs a million
dollars
it won't be 100 times better if you
spend 100 million dollars on it or if
you do 100 of them right
some experiments can be done for small
amounts of money some just need large
amounts of money and in the current
state of technology you can't do
high-energy particle physics in a very
effective way without spending a lot of
money so i think it is a unique kind of
project
where there's lots of justification for
trying to do it
on the other hand the justification is
not cut and dried because unlike with
the large hadron collider we don't have
a target right with the lhc we had the
target of the higgs boson and more
generally the electro weak scale where
we were hoping to find things we only
found the higgs so far we're still
hopeful to find something new but we
haven't yet
whereas if you build the next collider
without having found anything new at the
lhc you're just going on a fishing
expedition
if you find something it'll be
incredibly important the first super
direct obvious evidence of physics
beyond the standard model but i can't
promise you or even give you good odds
that we will find something for any
particular machine so that is a strike
against making uh spending a lot of
money on these machines it's a hard call
to make and i'm glad that i'm not the
one making it
eric stromquist says when people have
asked you in earlier amas about possible
mathematical realism about the world
you've said that you are a reality
realist instead
my question is but what about the
supervenience of low level physical
facts and structure on the mathematical
structure of whatever will be completed
physics to clarify i focus on
mathematical structure rather than
mathematics because mathematics is a
human endeavor that may be merely
nominalistic well mathematical structure
is what human mathematics purports to
describe atomistic objects like points
and set theory or category theory having
no intrinsic properties
but only relational properties with
other such atomistic objects the world's
actual structure is mathematical because
it would in turn supervene on the
correct mathematical symbology of
completed physics
so
i'll have to confess i just don't know
what this means in some sense you know i
know that people have
made claims about physical reality being
in some sense intrinsically mathematical
whether they're saying that it is math
in some sense like max tegmark might
want to gesture toward that i just don't
understand at all but even the slightly
weaker claim that somehow the physical
world
is a mathematical kind of structure
i don't know what that means i don't
know what the difference is between a
mathematical kind of structure and a
non-mathematical kind of structure i
mean is an apple a mathematical
structure because if i have two apples
and get two more apples i have four
apples i just don't know what it means i
know what it means to say that i can use
math to describe physical structures
that's what i do all the time that's
what physics does and i'm very happy to
do that but to somehow attribute
mathematicalness to a physical structure
i just don't know how to do that or what
it means so i don't think that there is
any issue here in my own mind i could be
missing something i'm not claiming to be
a super expert on this stuff but that's
how i think about it
jeff b says i was chatting with a friend
who was interested in physics and he
wrote the following
my theory is that the universe is an
inside out black hole and the event
horizon is the edge of the observable
universe
this explains the redshift of light we
see since black holes also have light
redshifted around them i knew there were
a few things that didn't quite seem
right about this but i usually listen to
you for quantum stuff rather than the
cosmology stuff so i wasn't exactly sure
how to respond can you respond for me
well you know look uh
that's not a theory to say the universe
is an inside out black hole is not a
theory for one thing it doesn't make
sense there's no such thing as an inside
out black hole i don't even know what
that means okay
um the universe is described by a
cosmological metric two very very good
um precision
i think the deeper issue here is that
well there's a whole bunch of issues um
one issue is that if you believe general
relativity at all
which presumably you do if you're
talking about black holes right they're
a prediction of general relativity
you've talked about black holes and
event horizons and black holes
redshifting light if you believe all
that stuff presumably you believe
general relativity then in general
relativity the universe is expanding or
contracting and empirically it's
expanding and that is the redshift
there's no need for an extra explanation
you cannot say i believe general
relativity but i don't think the
universe is expanding or contracting
that's just not how the equations work
okay so we already have explained this
you don't need a new explanation
furthermore and at a more detailed level
uh the redshift that is associated with
galaxies and quasars and so forth is not
just one phenomenon all by itself there
are many phenomena that fit together
the expansion of the universe the early
universe and nucleosynthesis the growth
of structure in the universe the fact
that there are gravitational time delays
as well as gravitational redshifts there
are many phenomena all of which fit into
the usual kind of picture and if you say
well the usual kind of picture is not
right i have a new picture you gotta
re-explain all of those phenomena okay
so if someone says you know i have a
theory about the universe that is new
and exciting just say all right in your
theory what is the ratio of hydrogen to
helium produced in the early universe
and when they tell you that ask them
what the amount of deuterium and lithium
is okay until you get to that level of
detail which the standard model explains
very very well
it's not really worth taking alternative
theories very seriously
kevin o'toole says whenever you discuss
a quantum field like the electron
positron field the mathematical object i
picture is basically like the electric
field i imagine a vector or at every
point in space or maybe a matrix or
something however i know this picture
can't possibly be correct because of
entanglement data at each point is a
local description so unless i'm missing
something it can't encapsulate
correlations that exist between distant
points in space so then what is the
correct mathematical structure to be
picturing
you know this is going to be one of my
deflationary answers here
you can't picture it sorry no one ever
does picture it you know it's not just
you
um
leonard suskind or edward whitton or
neymar connie hamed are all picturing
something like the electric field when
they picture a quantum field they know
it's not right right they know that
there are
other ways of thinking about it that are
purely mathematical right they can
calculate the correlation functions or
they can calculate the entanglement
entropy between different regions of
space they know how to manipulate the
thing but our visualization capacities
are just not up to the task we don't
have enough dimensions in our brain to
really think about entanglement between
a whole bunch of quantum fields at
different points in space so what you
should be thinking about is the
mathematical description of the quantum
state of these uh fields that you know
it might be not what you want to think
about but that's the correct way of
thinking about it
kaimana cook says do you think there is
something special and or real about the
present
uh no
i don't i mean my present self has
something real about the present but my
future self will have nothing special
about the present moment at every moment
there you there's stuff that exists and
that is the stuff that exists in the
present moment it's just a label it's
like saying is there anything special
about latitude 30 degrees north you know
it exists but there's nothing special or
ontologically distinct about it
jim murphy says what are your some of
your favorite live music experiences
um you know yeah i've gone to a bunch of
various kinds of concerts and so forth
uh i'm not nearly as big a music fan as
some other people are so i wouldn't get
uh i don't have the depth of experience
that some other people have you know my
the best live music experiences have
been at tiny little jazz clubs right
when i was at chicago i used to go down
to the new apartment lounge on the south
side and listen to von freeman play on
tuesday nights
deep into the evening and you know
sitting five feet away from the band
right and not the most elegant
surroundings but a wonderful melting pot
of different kinds of people locals from
the neighborhood music aficionados from
around the world students from the
university of chicago and so forth and
it was just tremendous fun and the band
was amazing you know improvising
in ways that you don't get to hear much
on the radio and things like that so i
would i would have to pick that as my
favorite kind of music experience don't
get it that much here in los angeles i'm
afraid
brendan krueger says if your brain was
strong enough to envision future events
down to the most fundamental scale of
physics would calculating a future state
of the universe in your head
temporarily create a new universe
so
i get the question and you know my the
initial
feeling is to dismiss it but i don't
think it's an easily dismissed question
upon further reflection but
i think what is so the idea here is that
if you're literally simulating
the complete behavior of everything in
the universe whether it's in your brain
or in a computer does that count as a
universe right because you're simulating
um
the whole thing that is going on so
this is the point of view advocated in
david chalmers's new book you know we
had david chalmers on the podcast a
while ago talking about consciousness
but his new book reality plus is exactly
advocating for the idea that if you
simulate something exactly then that
thing that you've simulated exists in
that simulation
and i get that i'm sympathetic to that i
haven't thought through all the pluses
and minuses so i can't
promise you that i would stick by that
position but in some sense i think the
answer to your question is yes but then
the there's a separate thing which is
the attitude one should have towards
such questions
which is
you're cheating a little bit you're
cheating a little bit by asking it
because you're literally saying if your
brain was strong enough to envision
future events down to the most
fundamental scale of physics okay
your brain is not strong enough nor will
it ever be nor could it be because the
point is you basically need your brain
to be as large as the universe to do
that at the level of simulating the
entire universe so what i'm saying is
that in order to physically realize this
kind of simulation
you basically would be creating a new
universe it's not just a matter of doing
you know mental exercises to improve
your thought processes it's a much more
dramatic
kind of thought experiment that you're
that you're doing here and i think that
we are a little bit too quick to
generalize the fact that you know i can
visualize in my head a game of chess or
checkers therefore why can't i visualize
everything in the universe it's just a
matter of degree right well sometimes
the matters of degree matter by a lot i
think this is the case
mikhail sirotenko says i'm now reading a
chapter about chaos in a book about
complexity after giving an example of an
equation that can lead to an
unpredictable result with any infinitely
small change of the input the author
concludes that this implies that perfect
prediction a la laplace is not possible
not only in practice but also in
principle
but is it if we build such a model of
the universe that takes only rational
numbers as in initial conditions we
still make exact predictions right
you know a lot of this depends on
what you mean by in principle and what
you mean by prediction okay
it remains true even in the presence of
chaotic dynamics that exactly specified
initial conditions lead to exactly
predictable future conditions okay
that's what laplace's demon says
what is being traded on in discourse
like this is that you never have access
to exact initial conditions for any real
physical system you can imagine
counterfactually if the initial
conditions were such and such rational
numbers then you could make the
prediction but the point being made is
you never know that that is the initial
condition and both things are true it is
both true that there is determinism that
given the exact initial conditions the
later final conditions are exactly
predicted and that you don't have access
to that
i personally think that this has nothing
to do
with chaos theory i mean people make it
into a big new
distinction that you know we discovered
this when we discovered chaos theory but
look laplace never thought
that in practice we were going to be
able to have perfect information
and without perfect information you
can't make perfect predictions
the dynamics of chaos theory help you
quantify how bad your predictions are
going to be
but we always knew they wouldn't be
perfect because you don't have access to
that information so i i don't think that
there's any big conceptual shift brought
on in the determinism discussion by the
fact that we now know that some dynamics
can be chaotic
andrew goldstein says
i'm probably conservative when i
estimate the number of academic
communication writing researching and
interviewing activities that you are
engaged in
so i ask how do you embrace and maintain
this extensive and diverse schedule not
to mention your personal life where you
presumably get to enjoy the realities of
nature that you so exquisitely
articulate
i mean i don't know i mean thank you for
the implied compliment there but uh as i
said before i've been fortunate enough
to be able to shape
a life a world a job where i can do a
little bit of all these different things
that i like it means that i'm not nearly
as devoted to any one of them as i could
be right i don't spend as much time
doing physics research as i could i
don't spend as much time and effort
writing books as i could or even the
podcast right
i i try very hard when i take on these
new activities
to limit them to limit the amount of
time it would take so for the podcast
it's literally limited to one day per
week i produce one podcast a week and
producing a podcast takes about a day
if it ever grows more than that i would
not be able to do it so
i mean i could do better about editing
or whatever
musical cues i don't know
but i'm not going to do that this is
this is what it's going to be
now i have a new job that involves
teaching and other new responsibilities
that i didn't have in the last couple
years so something might have to go
something else might need to be
downshifted uh we'll have to see about
that but it hasn't quite hit yet i
certainly don't have any secrets or
magic elixirs to get a lot of things
done i've just sort of been stubborn
enough to insist that i can do them and
lucky enough to be able to be given the
opportunity to actually make it happen
okay final question humberto nani says
during your podcast with leonard suskind
he answered your question about his
activities in the realm of writing the
theoretical minimum books by talking
about how he wanted to teach real
science versus crackpotism to his
parents and to his parents friends it's
a very touching story so besides us the
general audience is interested in your
videos and books on the biggest ideas is
there a particular set of persons you
are targeting
short answer is no or at least not in
general the longer answer is i target
different sets of people with different
things that i do so when i write a
textbook in physics i'm targeting one
set of people when i write a technical
paper in physics i'm targeting a
different set of people when i'm writing
a book it's a different set of people
when i'm doing a podcast it's yet a
different set of people when i tweet he
had a different set of people um
and as i said many times in many
different circumstances that's not the
only way to do it you know you can
absolutely i'm a big believer
in the power of specialization in the
right circumstances i think that the
problem with specialization is when
everyone is a specialist
i think that a healthy ecosystem needs
both generalists and specialists and
this is true for science but it's also
true for communication
so i i'm glad there are some people who
only write poems or only do podcasts or
whatever
and only
aim at a certain kind of audience uh you
know my audience is not universal i
don't aim at everybody every time you
know i'm not especially
good at or interested in writing for
kids for example i it is more my style
to assume some basic background
knowledge and maturity sometimes the
level is different you know in the
biggest ideas in the universe videos and
books
it's assuming more of the reader than
previous books have uh it's not assuming
necessarily background but it's assuming
a certain gumption in being able to go
through these equations and really try
to figure out what they're saying and
not everyone wants to do that and that's
perfectly okay
i would actually like to someday write a
book or some books that are aimed at an
even bigger audience an even wider
audience than what i've written so far
you know my uh
probably my
most pickupable book
uh
it was the particle the end of the
universe about the higgs boson but still
like there are chapters on gauge
symmetry and quantum field theory in
there uh you know the biggest i that
sorry the big picture
what was i tried to write it at a very
accessible level but it covers so many
things that it's not everyone's cup of
tea you know i would like to someday
write just a short sweet book that had
no equations in it that got something
important across but was you know
attracted to a very broad audience
haven't really done that yet so
the answer is there a particular set of
persons i'm targeting
different sets for different projects is
the
is the slightly weasley but completely
correct answer okay thanks everybody for
supporting the podcast on patreon uh it
warms my heart to have you doing this uh
hope you enjoyed the ama talk to you
next month
[Music]
you